the other night we had a very serious
attack in waukesha wisconsin a man drove
an suv through a parade
striking
many many many people there are a lot of
injuries
now
the motivation is a big question and we
try to tell everybody you know why don't
you wait a little bit till we can figure
out what's going on but it seems like
there's no clear motivation now the
police are saying it's not terror
related there was no pursuit
but also trying to make it seem like he
was fleeing from some kind of domestic
issue or some kind of knife fight which
makes no sense because he was not being
pursued
in that case maybe the story is an angry
man decided for no reason just in the
heat of the moment to ram through a
parade instead of turning off onto any
one of the side streets
or as one blm activist put it they think
it was retaliation over the rittenhouse
verdict and that the revolution has
started i don't know if i take that all
too seriously but i think what i do take
seriously is the fact that on both the
left and the right it is being viewed as
political or terror i shouldn't say
entirely on the left of course the
establishment left is trying to downplay
this and say oh nothing's happening
nothing's happening but when you have a
lot of you know activists on twitter
saying he was just defending himself or
this is what you get or things like that
or quite literally it sounds like the
revolution has started as the full
statement
uh maybe it sounds like the revolution
has started not because of what happened
because of what people are saying so we
definitely will get into that and we
also have an update on uh kyle
rittenhouse kenosha not so much written
house but there are civil lawsuits being
fired off already i believe one one more
than one so far two right two so far two
so far so we're gonna get in all that
stuff we've got some other stories too
but we've got uh two excellent guests
today and um
glad to have you rakeda law how did you
should introduce that introduce yourself
man yeah hey what's up i'm nick ricado
of rocata law a small law firm in
central minnesota very happy to be here
by the way thank you very much oh thanks
for coming man
and uh yeah i have a youtube channel
it's called ricata law we talk about
legal stuff and sometimes we talk about
you know ridiculous other cultural stuff
and anime because well that's cool well
i just wanna i wanna i wanna add that um
you say a small a small law firm but you
had a massive live stream during the
trial with this big panel of of of
lawyers so while the written house trial
is going on you are what everyone was
tuning in to for the most part and i
will say this
last week tuesday we had alex jones joe
rogan michael malus blair white me luke
you know uh drew hernandez we had 110
000 concurrent viewers for this big you
know crazy battle royale you you on your
stream of lawyers 130 plus thousand
people watching because you guys were
giving insightful an excellent
commentary into what was going on with
the trial in real time so that's that's
amazing so we're gonna we have a lot to
talk about i guess you have updates for
us too
yeah there was uh well we'll
we'll save it okay i was gonna preview
it but we'll we'll wait but it's related
to dominic black and this is this will
be really really interesting yes
something no you know no one has
probably talked about this or heard
about this so it's going to be pretty
cool cool right on pretending the guns
too uh we also have cash is back i'm
back
back yes what's going on guys
congratulations on your successful
tournament
yeah
i heard it was pretty awesome down there
yeah it was absolutely fantastic do you
want to introduce yourself uh cash patel
uh 16 years in government you can find
me at fightwithcash.com we're going to
get into it but i launched my merch site
tonight fight with cash dot shop and
special dick scout only for tim cast
viewers type in tim cast you get a
discount tonight oh wow
uh you also aside from working for the
trump administration and in government
you were a trial lawyer yeah i pretended
to be one for a while i was a public
defender and then i became a federal
prosecutor so i tried about 60 jury
trials to verdict in criminal cases uh
state and federal court it was awesome
and then i was just like i really want
to go make some money and so i stayed in
government oh oh boy all right then well
this will be great you guys be able to
talk to us about the trial we got we we
have a lot of updates we'll start with
the waukesha stuff we've got the rest of
the crew they're chilling yeah you know
i really don't like lawyers but i'm a
recovering but but you guys are okay you
guys are fine i'm kidding i'm really
excited about today's show and the shirt
that i'm wearing today i think um pretty
much says exactly the situation we're in
as it highlights the hunger games animal
farms they live brave new world the
matrix v for vendetta 1984 fahrenheit
451 all depicting your current reality
if you think this is an accurate
statement and wants to highlight it with
the rest of the world you can on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com get yours
before the supply chain shortages stop
you from getting it thanks for having me
over here we got the fun-loving internet
surfer what's up ian crossland happy to
be here baby let's go for the ride ian
looks like he's still in bed i am we're
still cold he just came out 70 degrees
in this room or something 65. and i am
also here i am ready to get educated on
law so let's get going before we get
started my friends we have a sponsor
tonight you know you love them biotrust
go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
51 off of your ageless multi-collagen i
have it right here i love the stuff you
don't really notice it i put it in my my
drinks my coffee and things like that it
kind of dissolves instantly i used to
say i put in my smoothies but i'm like i
haven't been having smoothies that much
later lately because i've been cutting
out the sugar but this stuff actually
has a kind of creaminess to your coffee
or drink and it's collagen you need it
your skin your bones your joints all
that good stuff so as you know we have
skate parks here i try to skate as much
as possible haven't so much in the past
week because we are traveling but uh as
i'm getting old now i try to make sure i
have this so make sure you go to
stronger bones in life you get a 60-day
money-back guarantee the healthy aging
support of collagen and its ideal forms
the five key types of college you need
from four different sources for every
order today biotrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help them hit their
goal of 6 million meals this year it is
non-gmo free of artificial colors
flavors preservatives and sweeteners
free of gluten antibiotics rbgh and rbst
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth or other collagen supplements and
there's no clumping you get free
shipping with every order free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of experts and uh for life
with every order and their new e-report
the 14 foods for amazing skin with every
order again stronger bones and life.com
and as i always say these are the
companies that are willing to back these
important conversations if we talk about
the stuff defending kyle rittenhouse
talking about these these court cases
these are difficult subjects and you
know they are right for cancer culture
so these companies are the companies
that truly support us so thank you again
to biotrust but don't forget go to
timcast.com
become a member
you will get access to the members only
segment we'll have one up tonight at
around 11 or so p.m but i want to point
out we have the green room episode this
is behind the scenes as we prepare for
our show with alex jones and ben stewart
so you might want to see this alice
wasn't on the show he just randomly
comes into our trailer so that's a
members only segment you can check out
but don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share this
show right now
smash the share button take that url
post it wherever you can help us out it
is the most important thing you can do
luke he has a history of doing that he
woke me up in my trailer last year
uh i think that's also on your sponsor
lounge as well it is actually one of the
oldest first sponsor video member videos
we have is alex jones storming into
luke's camper while he's sleeping and
waking him up that's the amazing contest
you get as a member first time seeing
him in 10 years after fighting and i'm
like
what the world standing over you in your
bed while you're like vulnerable
snapping
this is how it ends alex finally come
for me
but sharing helps it really does uh so
how about you smash that like button
let's jump into this first story we have
from the washington examiner check this
out uh as most of you know i want to be
careful it's a very serious subject i
mean it it is it is horrifying
watching what happened in waukesha if
you haven't heard a man took an suv and
he plowed into people just running them
over there's several casualties uh
dozens of injuries there is a very
horrifying video where a little girl is
just bouncing a little toddler bouncing
in the street and the car passes within
you know maybe a foot or two of this kid
and i'm just thinking the parents must
have been crying seeing what happened
and knowing how close their child came
this is horrifying and we want to know
what the motive is we don't necessarily
know everybody's speculating and it's
hard to say for sure but this guy
has a criminal record involving kids or
a child so that's very serious
but he's also a
black lives matter supporter he's
supported black nationalism he's been
critical of trump
and there's been a lot of speculation so
here's the story from from the examiner
black lives matter activist wonders
whether waukesha attack was linked to
written house verdict sounds possible
the revolution has started now
i'll throw i'll call out the examiner a
little bit here his his exact quote is a
little bit different from sounds
possible
and then they stop the then quote
revolution started he says
i believe his exact quote is
it but it sounds possible that the
revolution okay to be fair they're only
taking out a couple words he says but it
sounds possible that the revolution has
started in wisconsin it started with
this christmas parade this is a guy
named vaughn l maze now i don't think
it's fair to say this guy is calling for
it agreeing with it or otherwise but i
think it's important to note that this
guy not like he's a powerful influencer
that's his frame of mind that he sees
this and his immediate reaction was
retaliation over the written house
verdict many people on the right have
pointed out the same thing it is it is
two days not not even two days not even
two full full days from the written
house verdict when already tons of
leftists were saying
i'll be careful about high phrase but
threatening death on many people not
just kyle you have people going on
twitter saying retaliation revenge
something like this happens from a guy
who's been promoting the stuff on his on
his social media that's what it seems
like now i want to stress the police
have said there's no they do not believe
it's tear at this point they're saying
he was not being pursued he was fleeing
some crime which i think makes no sense
we have this from andy noe
he supported blm causes george floyd
black nationalism and he has a post
about how to run away
about running running people over on the
street and getting away with it
so
that being said
the big takeaway is not what his true
motive was and i say this often when it
comes to this stuff it's how people
react if the left and the right are both
reacting that this is political it
becomes political
yeah i think uh not just how they react
i agree with you on that um how people
react it becomes political it gives us a
pulse check on the country and where we
are we've been hearing this sort of
rhetoric kind of bubbling beneath the
surface in you know internet forums and
stuff over the past couple years but
it's becoming more and more of a
mainstream idea oh sorry i'll get on the
mic
but uh the
the other aspect of this is the media's
culpability
because the media has been
misrepresenting the kyle rittenhouse
case
for the past year and they've been
misrepresenting the case after the
verdict after the facts have come out
over and over again if you if you
watched our show we had the entire trial
streaming and you could see the actual
facts coming out in real time from the
witnesses who were there the media has
completely whitewashed over those facts
being put out there the only place
that's done anything to even mildly walk
it back is cnn saying oh we now found
out that the gun didn't cross state
lines that clip was amazing i don't know
if you guys have seen it but uh uh
they're like we've learned some things
in the trial and then they just rattle
off this huge list of everything they
they glossed over and got wrong that
we've all known since the beginning and
then when cernovich was like they're
basically they're scared of getting sued
the reporter responded with sir i am
just a reporter no one's making me say
this and i'm like
bull crap yeah they're just running
cover for the covington uh so they don't
have a repeat of the covington trial but
again i would go even further i would
say that the corporate media because
that's what they are they have been
race-baiting hustlers for the past two
years on an insane level pushing a
divide and conquered yeah i was gonna
say far longer far longer than two but
but ever since occupy wall street i
would say became more prominent but the
last two years has kind of crescendo in
this moment of insanity that really has
real life effects we saw the mainstream
media purport things that actually
resulted in people getting hurt injured
or killed in many instances social media
of course promoted that but look at look
at what cnn look at their headline today
their headline today was that uh it was
quote there's nothing more frightening
than an angry white man this is after
the tragedy day after yes hours after
five people died 48 people were injured
and this kind of thinking it's it's not
just an exception to the rule it is the
role for the corporate media this guy
he's speaking because he probably
watches a lot of corporate media there
was another illinois democrat that
almost said the same exact thing mary
lamonsky who said that this was karma
and that this was an act of self-defense
because kyle rittenhouse was acquitted
so these are mainline white women
karen's even talking about the same
points as this blm guy that you just
played that that just released that
video now how the police gonna come out
and say yeah the guy is political yeah
all these political people are
celebrating it but it's not terror
well look he's not wearing a turban i
mean to be fair yeah
but the left would immediately be like
that's not terrible i like the subjects
of today's conversation one karma i'm
like the resident indian so i'm
definitely able to talk about that
two we're talking about defamation and
we're going full turbine so i'm like i'm
ready
awesome but no i don't know if you know
this but that's why i started
fightwithcash.com it's liter i'm suing
new york times political and cnn for 150
million for defamation because of my
work during russiagate and trump
administration they literally defamed me
across the board and then when i left
government earlier this year people were
like i want to sue for defamation i
don't know how to do that so literally
the entire legal trust is i don't make a
dime we cut checks to lawyers who are
willing to take on defamation cases
across the country and that's what we're
doing and i'm glad you guys are fighting
the fight and if you need well let us
know i got good news for you i uh i
think at this point you could just be a
defamation lawyer and probably be rich
for the rest of your life just you you'd
never run out of work it's not hard work
i mean you know normally i remember
going back a few years and it's like
defamation and stuff and it's like well
how do you prove damages and how do you
prove this and how do you prove that and
these days it's like just give cnn five
minutes to report on the story yeah and
then you can sue them and it's clear
actionable
they're they're they're it's easy to
prove that they were wrong they knew
they were wrong and you just make some
money you know we'll call it sand
manning yeah well we have we have a
bunch of people doing that work right
sandman paved the way for going after
journalists project veritas has been
making huge headway um winning winning a
lot of pre-trial emotions in new york
that people didn't think they could win
new york reinforced its anti-slap
statute made it a lot stronger and they
went ahead and steamrolled right over it
in their case against uh against new
york times and and so the biggest bar to
a defamation lawsuit has been um can i
afford the lawyer to do it because
lawyers you know unless it's a really
clear case and a really clear case of
defamation is extremely rare you're not
going to find a lawyer taking it on
contingency they got to put in the hours
if you're going after someone like cnn
the amount of resources that have to be
expended to fight those guys is massive
so you can't just assume that you're
going to win and be able to recover i
want to i want to talk about a lot of
that in greater depth because we do have
a story there's civil lawsuits filed in
the written house case so we'll get much
more in depth on this but i want to
shift it back to
you know there's this tension that's
rising between the left and the right
following this what scares me is that
for the longest time
we have seen instances of some kind of
violence and immediately i mean let's be
honest the establishment the corporate
press is much more likely to do this
than the right is to the rights
disadvantage the cal right now is a
perfect example he he crossed state
lines with a gun he shot black people
like none of which is true but they just
keep saying it over and over again then
when it comes to you know other
instances you'll get the right or i
should not even necessarily the right
but the the anti-establishment the the
you know the establishment critical
whatever saying you know this might not
be political this might be random and
we'll try to make sure we're getting the
facts correct now i'm seeing a lot of
people say no revenge now that now i'm
seeing all these tweets from
conservatives saying i don't care why
the guy did it if he has any posts that
are pro black lives matter this was a
black lives matter attack if if we
escalate to that point and i think
the the establishment's driving it okay
this is going to contribute to more
chaos more clashes and it actually will
invoke more attacks and just make
everything worse yeah i mean there's a
lot of details here that we should talk
about but we should talk about it in an
honest perspective because there are
some people arguing that he was
deliberately turning into people when he
was driving he wasn't being chased he
called for political violence on white
people before he did refer to white
people as quote the enemy he was a huge
colin kaepernick fan there's a lot of
that last one that's it yeah that's
that's the thing i've heard is it all
colin kaepernick's fault of course not
no no but but some of these details do
matter and they do deserve to be talked
about in an honest real way where it's
not just pointing at people but but he
was an extreme criminal he had
he had an extensive criminal past he was
just released two days ago on a thousand
dollar bond which the milwaukee uh
county d.a was bragging about his bail
reform now of course he just came out
publicly and he admitted what he did was
a mistake bailing him out his his record
is is huge why was this man walk in the
streets which such a crazy extensive
record
i'm even saying that as not of a fan not
a fan of the the prison industrial
complex but but there's something that
needs to be discussed here that
obviously the corporate media is not
willing to discuss doesn't want to
discuss that highlights a lot of
nastiness within our society that does
deserve to be surfaced in my opinion
don't forget that one of the things that
he was being charged with was skipping
bail like so he actually has a record of
not having not honoring the bail
agreements that he has and so for them
to go ahead and then grant a reduced
bail to an absurd amount a thousand
dollar bail to put it in perspective in
in my tiny town uh my town is uh or the
big town near me is about 20 000 people
and um i had a guy on a
uh it's the lowest level of felony drug
possession charge you can have uh like a
class e felony and the bail for this was
possession of a little bit of thc was um
20 000 wow wow and and so this guy just
had a little bit of thc trying to lock
him up in prison he actually didn't have
any thc which was even better but uh but
yeah that was the the justification was
it was uh cbd oil and they said oh
there's probably thc in it wow it was it
was embarrassing but the bail on that
was twenty thousand dollars this guy
gets a thousand dollar bail he's got a
rap sheet that uh is significant with
felonies on it there's 25 mug shots in
multiple states that's all i have yes
but but twenty thousand dollar bail that
means two grand down right that means
two grand in minnesota in wisconsin they
have uh well two grand down but if you
uh if you
go ahead and honor the bail agreement
you don't get any back um because that's
you're paying that fee to a bondsman so
um a bondsman will put up your twenty
thousand in exchange for ten percent i
see in wisconsin they don't allow that
in wisconsin it's cash bail uh they
don't allow you to full
full amount so that's why kyle had to
pay the two million dollars uh on his
bail in illinois isn't it like you pay
up ten put up ten percent or something
yeah some states have that built in
other states use bail bondsman to do it
uh wisconsin it's the full cash amount
so his would be the equivalent still of
a ten thousand dollar bail in minnesota
but that's that's nothing i mean and
right
it's absolutely embarrassing this guy
with several felonies and skipping bail
on his record that that so like this
case highlights like people who actually
want to do criminal justice reform and
bail reform and bond reform look i've
argued a thousand bail hearings okay on
the defense and prosecution side right
and there's some nasty guys that get let
out and then there's some really rich
guys who shouldn't get out but get out
because they got a lot of money right
and this kind of conversation we're
having actually goes back to that which
is where the conversation should be but
when cnn and everybody else jumps in and
starts talking about race and hurling
fake news and making up facts that don't
exist then we overlook the biggest
problem yeah i don't think there's like
a normal human being on planet earth
that thinks this guy should have been
out on bail 21 years as a convicted
felon running around town skipping bail
convicted of serious aggravated felonies
and oh by the way what was he on bail
for previously punching the mother of
his child and running her over twice
allegedly yep right so okay is that not
a violent crime
um maybe and what's he doing on bail you
have this defund police movement that
comes in and it's just sort of it's an
avalanche and what these prosecutors now
do is they just curtail themselves to
the whims of the media and they're like
well this is this is the right thing to
do we should just give everybody bail
and i was like i never heard that when i
was a public defender do you think
cnn producers cry themselves to sleep at
night
i'm not joking they might cry in their
sleep i'm i think only if they're honest
i don't know but no no but let's be real
like
they're regular people who work at these
companies these media companies and sure
maybe brian stelter twirls his mustache
before bed doesn't cry you know that
that's a guy who goes on tv every day
and just without pants well he doesn't
comb his hair
well yeah lack thereof but uh but look
there's a lot of things he said that are
just so outrageous and obvious it's like
man and this guy claims to be a media
reporter truth be told people didn't
understand this about brian stelter's
show is that it's often about nothing
like uh i was when i was flying back
from austin i was watching it and he was
talking about something that was totally
irrelevant it's like in the weeds media
stuff so irrelevant to people who work
in media but then when he gets into like
fake news and then he just makes stuff
up or just lies or whatever it's like
does this guy even really care no no i
don't think he does but
we've seen the the veritas videos of
people who are like man we used to do
news there's like a guy sitting in a
room and he's just like i remember we
used to go out and do reporting now it's
just we just do panels about trump
like i'm willing to bet that there are
some people
who are just producers man they're just
people who want to operate the camera
and want to get the story out and
they're sitting there every day and it
probably feels like their hearts in a
vice every day they got to go in msnbc
too i mean look look at this tucker
carlson used to be on msnbc they used to
have like republicans conservatives
moderates there are people who have
probably been in that company for a
decade 15 20 years maybe and they've
watched all this happen and they're
probably crying at night i'm not even
kidding imagine you put in two decades
at a big network that used to do good
reporting and good opinion stuff and now
it's rachel maddow
you're probably just sitting in bed
crying asking where it all went wrong i
don't think there's a lot of those
people though i mean i'm in a lot of
these studios every week doing hits i'm
not on cnn or anybody i'm suing but you
meet a lot of the people the everyday
people that make it happen the cameraman
the editors the writers the people
who've been there for 10 15 20 years and
most of them have been subjugated by the
big corporate media cnn msnbc of the
like they basically don't allow you to
work there unless you agree with their
top line which is what they're promoting
at the end of the day i go into fox for
example right i'm not i'm not making
this up half the people at fox are
democrats
they're in new york
city and they don't they don't fire them
they don't bury their voice they just
come in and do their job and they know
who the hannities of the world are but
during occupy wall street when geraldo
showed up and the activists all
surrounded him screaming fake news and
they were throwing water on him the
sound guy yelled i needed a job
something like that like that dude
clearly was not happy working for this
network and people were screaming and it
was like it's just a job i need work i
needed the money and there's like
screaming at him fake news
i think i kind of feel like
you know i worked for some of these
companies a few years ago and i watched
how they changed and i left immediately
like i worked for vice vice i wanted to
work there because they were you know uh
shane smith the ceo and one of the
founders said on stephen colbert we're
not left we're not right we're not
republican democrat we just you know
we're storytellers we want to talk to
people and we don't want to be a part of
that and i'm like man that spoke to me
right and then i go and work there and i
watch the changes and i watch the slow
things and then eventually i'm like i
should go somewhere else a new start i
go to an abc company thinking it was a
new joint venture it was not the same as
the corporate hqs and in the first few
months they really were like do your
thing you know
it's like they called it nice vice like
don't cuss and do the weird stuff with
hookers but you know go
go do the field reporting but then
within eight months they were like we
decided we're all gonna become woke
feminists and i'm like can i leave could
i not be here so i watch like you know
there are probably people there who had
good intentions and now it's just become
they're they're stuck in these machines
and i mean what do you do look we talk
to people all the time on this show they
comment they're saying i can't just up
and quit my job i can't just leave i
have a family and things like that
imagine working for cnn over the past
four years and you're like
what do i do with the ratings going down
you're not finding a new job they're
doing layoffs you're lucky to have work
nah they're crying themselves to sleep
well another thing to really kind of
think about here is that a lot of these
high-level people a lot of these like
top journalists
majority of them have major substance
abuse problems i remember once i got
drunk with the white house press corps
at bilderberg and they could drink like
fish it was absolutely awestunning and
then when you look look at the inner
workings all of them are using one
substance or another whether it's big
pharma whether it's illicit substances
they're off getting high to the extent
where they don't have to realize what
they're doing because if they did they
would be absolutely mad with themselves
because i mean look at the headlines
msnbc had another headline today talking
about how thanksgiving is white people
celebrating genocide and violence
against blacks
how does that make any logical sense at
all it doesn't you know cnn msnbc all
these people are literally regurgitating
scripts that they're given and the
scripts are becoming more ridiculous by
the day so so to see them as drug
addicts actually makes a lot of sense
when you see what actions they're
capable of doing and the atrocities that
they're responsible for on the general
public in my opinion i i don't know who
tweeted this out i can't find it but i'm
pretty sure rachel maddow said the
dossier was fun was backed by russia
like she finally came out and said she
said that i'm pretty sure i i saw a
tweet from someone from a very david and
i are going to go on our show and make
her say it again make her say it again
so maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm wrong i'll
be here i i haven't pulled it up or
anything but i was scrolling through
twitter and someone posted a quote and
it's like rachel maddow saying much of
the dossier
you know blah blah blah was it was was
you know what was was uh was created was
it sourced by uh chris christopher
steele or whatever but it was actually
coming from russian sources or something
like that yeah i mean so yeah as the guy
who ran the russia gate investigation
this one always you know rings true with
me we knew five years ago that the dnc
and hillary clinton campaign paid for it
screwed up the fbi
perpetuated the biggest fraud but for
five years this is everything we're
talking about today in like you know in
less than 30 seconds the media just ran
with it they just ran with the false
narrative even though we had the
information we produced at the american
public they didn't want to review it
it's not that racial matter didn't have
access to some of the facts right she
had access to adam schiff the biggest
you know clown in america but they
didn't want to put out the facts what
was that was it the new york times said
about veritas that their reputation is
so bad that we can't possibly harm it
but so basically what they're saying is
let's let's break down what they said in
that regard i i i could be wrong about
that because i don't have the documents
in front of me i'm pretty sure new york
times said they're they're you know
undefamable or something right yeah
bible proof right what the media what
what new york times is basically saying
there is
because we're a gang and we can all beat
you up at the same time you can't blame
me for swinging the crowbar because 10
people were already swinging it it's
like uh i understand that snowflake
doesn't blame itself for the avalanche
but uh yeah we'll just sue everyone with
the crowbars you can't claim that
because all of the media's smearing
veritas you get to as well to the uh to
the judge in that case is credit and
again the reason they were going with
libel proof is it would be
if the judge were to determine they were
libel proof then they would dismiss the
case and new york times would be able to
go after project veritas for their
attorney's fees
to the judge's credit he basically said
exactly what you did yeah they're only
libel proof because you're citing each
other all of these news publications are
just citing other news publications all
saying the same thing with the same kind
of basic source behind it that you guys
don't like them that doesn't make
someone libel proof if a whole bunch of
people gang up on someone and say the
same thing that doesn't make you libel
proof if the underlying thing isn't true
so the
they got lucky with the with the judge
in that case occasionally you get a
judge who will actually go through apply
the law as uh and apply some logic and
reason with the law and uh and this guy
seems to have been doing it so yeah uh
they are lucky there was there were some
updates in the veritas stuff i think the
court ordered the new york times to stop
publishing their privileged
communications and the new york times
said no
and then i think the judge responded
with excuse me like
i i was so this is this is a really big
part of the whole defamation process
what's happening with veritas and like
the defamation as a whole
that
the new york times is being sued by
veritas
they
are given access to veritas's privileged
legal communications which basically
just interfered entirely with the
court's process with veritas's process
and they did it with a smile on their
faces i have to imagine when the judge
found out he was probably like yo you're
spitting on me now like i gotta deal
with this stuff and you have access to
their you know what's gonna happen if i
rule on this veritas is gonna file so
many complaints that i'm gonna get
overwhelmed on everything i mean what
are your guys's thoughts on how the
judge would react to someone again
you know
i mean i i had not heard about the
privileged communication thing how how'd
they do you know how they got asked it
is it is believed the fbi oh okay so
sorry i did hear about that i did hear
about that my my mistake yeah um
i got to imagine the judge was like
fuming there there are very limited
circumstances in which a judge can put a
prior restraint on on speech of a party
um and and you know this would be one of
those sort of situations look you got
access however you got it to their
privileged attorney-client
communications you should never have
seen that that stuff uh should be
privileged from everybody including the
fbi and so now no you can't go out and
start publishing it it's not press
worthy it's not newsworthy you're just
trying to gain an advantage over your
lawsuit opponent that's the time that
this should happen um if they keep it up
you know the judge hopefully will resort
to sanctions and heavy sanctions yeah i
mean look judges uh you know the one
whether they're appointed by a
republican a democrat or liberty
whatever doesn't matter the one thing
they hate more than anything is getting
reversed it doesn't matter at what level
or state federal county local appeals
court they hate being told i got it
wrong and what this guy's doing is if i
have to rule on this like you said tim
he's going to issue all these rulings
and then they're going to contest them
and he's afraid that they might actually
some crazy appeals court might actually
come down and say actually legal
privileged communications in this
instance are okay for whatever mickey
mouse reason that the media trumpeted so
i think he's playing it pretty pretty
good and pretty safe and that he's
probably avoiding trying to issue an
actual ruling that can be appealed but
he's trying to get the lawyers to get in
line with the fbi and support the
privileged communication
and we we saw this uh with the written
house case right bru uh judge schroeder
he was so hesitant to issue a definitive
ruling on anything even on the
evidentiary issues pre-trial he says
i'm going to
uh i'm going to
hold off on this with a with a
predisposition towards keeping them out
it's like that's that's not a ruling
just just say this can't come in or this
can come in and then you can you can
change your mind later you're a judge
you can do that but i think i think a
lot of us are happy with some of the
rulings from the judge in the written
house case but his inability to issue a
ruling on the fake evidence admitted by
the prosecution has resulted in uh uh i
see this is what antifa is putting out
in in spades they're they're posting
news clips that say prosecutors showed
video they say is of kyle rittenhouse
pointing a gun at activists
that's it
and now they're saying now all the
antifa is going kyle rittenhouse was
waving a gun around threatening people
and when they tried to stop him he
killed him and the judge let him get
away with it
the judge if he if he had a stronger
spine i'll say he has some of the spine
because he did dismiss the gun charge he
did do some rulings he could have said
that's a computer generated image out
sorry
let me know what you think because my
argument was the defense had no idea how
to explain that the prosecution admitted
cgi evidence my my thought process was
the defense should have asked the expert
when was the image file
created and he would have said last week
so this image file was not created on
august 25th 2020 no it was not your
honor this image is not from the night
in question i will it be you know
admissible or something
that that's one way to go about it the
other way is simple
they had tons of evidentiary issues in
this case
normally you have to have someone who
will testify that the thing that you're
looking at is a fair and accurate
representation of the thing that
happened and the only guy they had
testify about this footage was a
detective who looked at it on his iphone
and when you really factor in the fact
that a capital murder case the entire
theory of the prosecution got blown out
in the first half that's why this
footage came in and they had to change
their entire strategy and in a kid's
life in a capital murder case hangs on
the idea that a detective who was not
present that night
pinched to zoom on an iphone and thinks
he saw something that he can't replicate
because he didn't record that pinch to
zoom there's no way for the defense to
look at it challenge the authenticity of
it say that there's interpolation adding
pixels um they they tried sort of to
ham-fist their way into that argument uh
but
but at the end of the day what they
needed to do was just say your honor
there's no way anybody here can testify
that the picture we're seeing now is a
fair and accurate representation
it worked
the uh i i you know i gotta be as i
don't know if the prosecution actually
cared about the end results that's going
to
the cultural impact but then you get
people posting these things the black
lives matter supporters saying written
house was pointing a gun
then you get people believing the latest
attack was a retaliation
so let's throw we'll bring it back to
this veritas thing you you mentioned
this judge uh he's not like he basically
is not really trying to rule on the fact
that the new york times has access to
their legal documents which in my
opinion
i don't know how they can continue the
court proceedings
at that point
so that the judge seems to be doing
nothing is that the gist of it uh i i
don't know what the judge has said about
it um i've just heard about the uh the
disclosure by the allegedly by the fbi
uh to project veritas's enemies with
that being said i mean if the judge is
not issuing a gag order on some of this
stuff then he's hesitant to try and
restrain the press and i think at this
point he well he did uh the judge said
stop publishing sure veritas's
privileged communications the new york
times said no
we have a first amendment right to
report the news and we have a story
right here it's from uh today actually
new york times urges no prior restraint
against veritas coverage
uh basically saying veritas's claims do
not implicate the kind of extraordinary
public harms national security that
american courts have suggested okay blah
blah blah i don't care what they're
arguing here let's get a little bit
hypothetical then my question is
you've got
person a suing person b
person b illegally obtains person a's
communications with their lawyer as it
pertains to this lawsuit
how could a judge issue how could a
judge handle that case i mean he's got
to throw it out it's just it's straight
up privilege but here's the thing right
there's unfortunately it's happened
before when bob mueller's u.s attorney
in massachusetts he actually had a
criminal case where he uh surveilled a
client and their attorney's conversation
and utilized in the prosecution came
back to bite him in the butt uh in a in
one of the biggest narco trafficking
cases out of florida same thing the u.s
attorney's office obtained the
communications between the defendant and
his lawyer and didn't disclose it now in
those criminal cases it's a little
different right there's a harsher
penalty because due process is at stake
but the rule of law is the same it's a
privileged communication all you need to
ask new york times is if they're okay
with this then what project veritas
should do is be like fine give us all of
new york times privileged communications
oh the judge could be like yes and
release it to the general public and
make everyone see it i mean that's what
the new york times is doing right now
yeah go ahead then we just see all the
emails where they're like don't cover
epstein yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like oh
yeah yeah that story we gotta we gotta
make sure it doesn't go anywhere just
like of course cbs news like which
project veritas exposed was hiding a
huge expose which they had according to
one of their reporters they had i think
i'm joking clinton and other presidents
so again they were covering that story
but vanity fair had a very interesting
take on this because again it's all
about framing and the way that these
people just frame stuff is just so
disingenuous they had an article that
was titled press freedom advocates
alarmed that project veritas just
muzzled the new york times that's their
understanding of the situation and again
it's it's it's it's so mind-boggling to
see this kind of like twisting and
turning and installation of basic facts
to push a narrative and an agenda here's
the only good thing that comes to this
if like you were saying earlier you know
lawyers are expensive these suits are
expensive but when you bring them and
they're credible they take one to two
years at the end of it you actually get
some really good rulings on what we call
case law precedent if these cases
survive but what these guys try to do is
drown them out like veritas isn't going
anywhere right right these guys are
actually if i was at times lawyers i'd
be like you need to sit down and shut up
because we might squeak out of this case
but you are going to mess up the future
of defamation for defendants if you keep
down this track because the judge will
force he can't he might not issue now or
in a month or six months but in a year
he's going to have to make some rulings
and those rulings will likely get
appealed and then affirmed its law are
judges obligated to uh
stick to case law like if someone says
in the case of supposed to theoretically
yeah
they're they're uh they're supposed to
call follow binding authority and the
idea is that uh they'll get reversed and
as cash said earlier uh if they get
reversed that's the worst thing a judge
wants to do um there's not much
practical effect for lifetime federal
judges but new york state judges aren't
lifetime appointees um and and so there
there are there could be real effects
for for them but imagine just just
rolling it back if this stands if what
new york times is doing stands what's to
stop any news publication whoever gets
sued from just illegally obtaining the
privileged communications of their of
their opponents and and publishing and
shaming them that's why this judge has
to go ahead and issue the order and if
if new york times doesn't like it take
it to the supreme court go ahead appeal
it up to the to the new york court of
appeals and then appeal it to the united
states supreme court call it a first
amendment issue freedom of the press if
you want and let them determine it
because then uh you know if we get that
case on the books okay fine but at the
end of the day uh judges do have some
limited ability to issue a gag order
when there is sufficient justification
and i can't imagine how illegally
obtaining your opponent's privileged
communications and then trying to
publish those privileged communications
to shame them would not meet maybe maybe
i'll get my lawyer in my defamation case
against the times to file for the times
is
uh privileged communications and then
send them out and what's the times argue
going to be they're going to be like uh
well we previously arguments like this
right like here's an article from new
york times no i have to i have to
imagine
that when it comes to losing in court
it's when you directly try to affect the
judge's powers and their ability to do
their job so it's like you know you go
in front of judge a judge and you're
like this guy kicked my dog and the
other guy is like i didn't kick his dog
and it's like here's a video i'm kicking
my dog he owes me 100 bucks the judge is
like i am involved in this
uh i think the evidence stands and the
judge you know the issue of ruling or
however it goes um
what happens when you have someone
saying your honor i'm going to attempt
to directly interfere with your ability
to rule on this because screw you i
should be allowed to do it i feel like
that's the fastest way to lose there's
just no world that i can imagine being
in and i've appeared in court probably
three thousand times that if i ever said
that to a state court judge or a federal
judge the federal court judge would
probably lock me up for contempt of
court for being so arrogant remember
when christ he'd just be like what or
she
didn't kraus talk back like several
times in the written house trial which
is insane to me because like don't get
brazen with me i know i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure i was watching you guys when
you guys were like oh whoa like don't
talk back to a judge are you nuts
yeah big court's a little different i
mean you know this is the one we talked
about a couple weeks ago the reason we
get such a wide berth in the written
house case state courts allow cameras
but no federal report in america allows
a camera which is why you get those
cartoon caricatures so state court
almost becomes movie-like so there's a
little more freedom i mean you're not
supposed to talk back against the judge
period i never did that um but there's a
little more freedom because they also
get like a little i mean this guy's like
one of the most famous judges in america
right now
oh yeah
these these guys first of all they're
lawyers so they have egos going in
second of all they're given a robe that
tells them they get to decide the fate
of lives
every single day and that their
decisions have the force of government
behind them so you can imagine like just
the audacity of telling the government
no and the government having a
mouthpiece with a with a human ego
behind it to say no yes i mean so so
basically the new york times gets a hold
of veritas's lawyer communications about
how they operate what they're doing
while they're being sued by veritas
which directly impacts their their the
lawsuits and the judge said stop
publishing this stuff
and new york times said shut up judge i
can't i have to imagine it's like this
is
sanction them sanction them and let them
take it to the let them take it to the
supreme court maybe they win what would
that happen well this is also on the
heels on the fbi rating james o'keefe
and his employees uh apartments taking
their cell phones away from them because
cash when you said i want my lawyers to
do this i was going to recommend you
also get an intelligence agency to go
after your enemy yeah bust down their
doors and take away their cell phones
and take their communications that way
and then you can release it to the
general public without even involving
the job so in the other instance
actually i think my friend harmeet was
representing james o'keefe in in
verizon's case she actually got that
judge to issue a ruling and and stand
down the communications going over
that's the right way to do it that's
what this judge should be doing but
didn't he do that i thought i thought
harmeet posted this yeah the judge on
that first ruling i'm saying right right
privileged communication oh it should be
the same exact thing like there's
there's not really a difference there in
terms of the law like you can't one you
don't have access to that information
too you can't be putting it out if you
don't have lawful access to it in the
first place and there's no difference
evil people
you know because it's like we can agree
to disagree on a lot of things but when
you're like your fundamental rights
are void because i'm a journalist i'm
like nah you're just evil like the idea
that okay so when it comes to the united
states comes the constitution comes to
what we believe other people are
afforded they're afforded their legal
defense the right to due process
if you think we have a first amendment
right to take away your right to due
process i'm like nah that doesn't work
that way that would be like someone i
have a right to guns so i'm going to rob
people no it doesn't work that way yeah
basically what they're doing
yeah i i agree it's it's uh and it's
it's the arrogance and i would say the
death rattle of a lot of major media
companies we've seen we've seen
competition growing i mean heck this
show is competition for mainstream media
they know it they know about independent
media and and how it's been changing the
landscape over the past really uh decade
or more and and they're now lashing out
and that's why that's why they hate
veritas right because veritas is started
by a guy who goes out and does the
things that media used to do
and they can't control the narrative
they can't stop someone like project
veridas they can they can give them a
roadblock here or there but they can't
do it uh and and the more independent
voices that come out the more we're
gonna see this sort of uh retaliation
let's talk about this uh we got uh from
cbs denver
denver attorney filed civil action in
kyle written house shooting now before i
actually read what it's about i want to
stress i was browsing reddit earlier and
there's a tweet from a guy not even a
link to the story they don't even have
the decency to actually post the link
they post a screenshot of a tweet not
even a link to the tweet no decency to
even put the tweet post the tweet link
and the guy says breaking news the first
civil lawsuits and the rite house trial
have been filed and all of the comments
are saying things like kyle rittenhouse
is going to lose this lawsuit because
civil lawsuits are easier to win than
criminal cases and it's just a wave of
people being like kyle's going to lose
kyle going to lose and then finally like
you know i'm down a hundred or so
comments i see one guy say who's gonna
tell them
they're suing the city and not kyle
rittenhouse
the lawsuit no one's no one so far
they're not suing kyle
the big money for anybody who wants to
sue is in the city and you know what i
agree
for the people uh so you've got like
jacob blake's family they're suing the
police okay i don't know about all that
the guy was grabbing a knife and
fighting with cops that's a that's an
uphill battle yeah yeah say the very
least but but for the the anthony hoover
they're suing i'm like oh yeah the
police should have been out there
stopping the riots
so if they're if they want to sue on
that grounds i mean that's a tough one
though like the cops should have been
trying to stop the guy from doing what
he was doing
that was the crime no no no no if the
police were actually out stopping riots
there would have not been anything and
if hubert hadn't been rioting then there
wouldn't have been a problem well the
supreme that's a good point
the supreme court ruled that police
officers have no duty to protect and
serve the the citizen so that's also
going to be something that's going to be
leveraged here i think because again
that's something that
that was said as a president i think ian
nailed it actually i mean probably an
uphill battle when they're like we're
suing you and it's like well we maybe we
should have been protecting you but you
were the one doing what would need to
protect people from yeah right right now
uh by by nature being dead i think huber
has the best lawsuit against the city
not that that's saying he has a good
chance but gage who's alive went on the
stand and admitted that he lied in his
civil lawsuits against the city by
omitting the fact that he had a gun with
him that he that he brought that and and
that's under oath he can never walk that
statement back i mean they're trying to
they're doing their little media apology
tour that he started the next day after
his testimony he's showing up on uh
michael strahan's show and then going on
uh some other show after he was on good
morning good morning america his first
show that he debuted on and they were
treating him like a celebrity
when his perjury charges coming exactly
i was just going to ask him i was going
to ask you guys is he going to face any
charges oh no no he's not going to get
perjury because it'd be the kenosha
county prosecutor's office let me uh let
me tell me you guys you know you're
you're a lawyer you're a recovering
lawyer tell me if if you think i'm on
point here
i think some of this is obvious
but uh here i'll speculate um
gage grosskroitz had a second doi in
january of 2021 i believe it was six
days before the written house trial it
was dismissed on a motion of the
prosecution
uh gage grosskroyd's
had a assigned search warrants to get a
signed search warrant against him for
his cell phone that the prosecutor told
the police not to execute
gage um
seems like
you know he had this he also had this 10
mil let me slow down he did have i
believe was a 10 million lawsuit was
against the city or the police the city
uh i believe it was the city the city he
had a 10 million lawsuit against the
city over what happened
but then he testifies under oath
contradicting his own lawsuit which
clearly means he's going to lose so it
sounds to me like they went to him and
said you have two choices you can plead
the fifth move forward with your lawsuit
maybe you win 10 million bucks
and your second choice enjoy that money
while you're rotting in prison because
we're going after you with the full
weight of everything on your second dui
on your gun charge we're going to get
you an attempted murder of kyle
rittenhouse and he probably said i will
do anything you say
yeah so there's there's an interesting
thing with pleading the fifth um you
have an absolute right to plead the
fifth in criminal court and it cannot be
used against you you cannot draw a
negative inference from it in fact we
saw that bingo just toeing the line of
mentioning
kyle rittenhouse's fifth amendment
rights almost got the case entirely
dismissed at that point in time
but when you plead the fifth in in a
criminal suit or in a civil suit with
pending criminal charges or anything
like that
the other party is allowed to draw a
negative inference from the issue so if
i ask gage the question uh you know did
you provoke this incident incident and
he says i plead the you know i plead the
fifth or did you bring a gun to this i
plead the fifth they're allowed to draw
the negative inference that yes he did
bring the the gun with him or yes he did
the defense cam yeah the the the other
party of the civil lawsuit oh it's not
criminal so right the criminal and the
criminal lawsuit uh has to be ignored
here but when you have parallel suits
you've got this criminal case where he's
a complaining witness so he's basically
a party along with the state and then
you have this civil case if he pleads
the fifth in that criminal case then the
civil case the city gets to use that
against him and so he was uh the
prosecutor may have made a deal like
that that's certainly possible and i i
think binger was out making tons of
shady deals and and various threats to
certain witnesses um and and just
ignoring jump kick man entirely and they
knew who he was right the defense
actually came out said that was withheld
from them yeah well to be fair when he
went into the the da's office asking for
a deal they all looked up at the ceiling
so they didn't know he was there yeah
you know right that was fine but but
yeah in in that case if he were to uh
plead the fifth in his criminal lawsuit
it would basically tank his civil
lawsuit because the city from a
prosecutor's perspective
look i did it too you know your flex is
to go to other people and say i'm gonna
prosecute i would go into a massive
conspiracy and be like here's 16
defendants who wants to chirp
literally be like first one to me go
everybody else is going down because but
at that point i knew i had the evidence
i wasn't bluffing the case right i was
saying i can use some assistance and i
don't need to put 16 people away because
you also know that like not everybody is
as culpable as the next guy there's
different levels of it right so from a
prosecution's perspective not everyone
should go down for the same amount of
time just because they were involved in
the whole thing so that's where you get
some wiggle room i think this prosecutor
is crazy and probably just went in there
didn't have his case together and was
just like walking the big walk and
trying to say i'm going to do what i
want i'm going to pound my chest i'm
going to go on tv i'm going to make the
world's greatest case since oj except he
you know i think i think uh kraus
tampered with all the evidence i don't
know if you saw my twitter throughout
about it it's it's speculative to be
completely fair but i think it's
speculative only in one key area what do
we know
the drone footage they admitted which
was their their special key evidence
that showed kyle they claimed to be
pointing a weapon which it didn't show
by the way it was too blurry it was
nonsense but it came in a weird form at
8 44. that was that was the it was it
was 1920 by 844 so it was cropped
someone took footage that appeared on
tucker carlson
cropped out the top yeah presumably from
tucker carlson's show and removing the
uh the fox graphic
it was then further cropped and
compressed
renamed and sent to the defense
i think you know this stuff kraus has a
cropping software format factory and
compression software handbrake on his
laptop
so here's what i was talking to this
antifa guy and he said yo man like
that's wildly speculative for you to be
claiming that stuff and i was like well
hold on hold on hold on
evidence that was given to the defense
was cropped and compressed
the prosecutor who gave the evidence to
them that way has cropping software
specifically for cropping and
compression software which is
specifically it's transcoding but one
was like it does cropping and mixing one
does compression so look i'll put it
this way if i see a person on the ground
with a stab wound and then i see a guy
holding a bloody knife
okay i'll admit it is for me speculating
to say that guy with the knife stabbed
the person on the ground they call being
caught red-handed but i also think it's
fair to say the person with the with the
weapon in question that was used
presumably this same kind of weapon to
kill someone and they're right there
i mean i don't know if you agree with me
on that one
well the the thing making it even worse
is uh whether or not krause cropped the
the footage and compressed it one it was
idiotic of them to use a laptop that had
anything other than uh we saw it with
the defense right and during the jury
deliberations they said we have a clean
laptop the only thing on it is vlc
and the files that they need to view
that's it there's there's nothing else a
sanitized laptop and what what's a
laptop that can play video cost 300
bucks you can go you can go to target
and buy one um so you know that that's
not a problem why the state had a laptop
with that software on it along with
other evidence is baffling
but the problem with it is that kraus
stood up and he said i don't know
anything about compression i don't know
anything about you know how you
manipulate these video files and then we
see because of their mistake of of
having this stuff on this computer we
see it there and it's like
look i know about compression i know
about cropping video i don't have
handbrake like
so so someone who has it you're like
okay why do why do you have this if you
don't know anything about it and and the
state shouldn't be manipulating and
cropping evidence anyway they send it
off to the crime lab to do that so extra
nonsense why can't we how come we don't
have leaders who are willing to actually
make a move
i'm talking about the judge here
he thought he's going to ask he
intimated putting the prosecution on the
stand under oath so this is what this is
on the spot this is well most judges
don't do that they can do that this is
what this judge should be doing the
trial's over right he can be issuing
instituting content proceedings on his
own there's no defense in prosecution in
that scenario every judge has this right
if he thinks to to your point if he
thinks someone lied that appeared before
him that's a contempt proceeding against
that person the nbc news reporter person
that was chasing around the jury right
um that in my opinion is one of the most
egregious things you can do is
intimidate a jury that's an actual crime
but let's set aside the crime what can
the judge do the judge can haul in that
person and nbc news and say who gave you
that instruction to follow the jury what
was your instruction and what were you
supposed to do and if he lies contempt
of court and the penalty for contempt of
court is going to prison or he can find
you as much money as he wants to he
should be doing that he can how long uh
contempt how long can they send you to
prison for
is it jail or is it prison i think it's
up to a year it's up to a year per count
yeah and then you can stack them
and the judge just decrees it right
right and the money there's no real like
limitation i mean you can't go wild but
you can find a company a lot of money
for being held in contempt that's the
power that judges are supposed to wield
to keep these people in check especially
when prosecutors lie to their face but
when there's an acquittal this judge is
probably my guess just gonna be like i'm
not going to do anything anymore when
someone where where are the leaders
there's no good someone who gets hit for
contempt if they lie about the same
thing over and over do they get a
contempt charge every time
you can you can it's doable right that's
what's supposed to happen when
prosecutors bury or withhold exculpatory
evidence evidence of you know innocence
or doctor evidence the only remedy for
that is not the state or the federal
government bringing a case it's for the
judge to come in and say
i'm gonna hold you in contempt show me
why i shouldn't and as the judge likely
to say look
britton house is going home that's it i
gotta work with these guys look i've
been there they're gonna be there in my
chambers again and again and again if i
start a conflict that can't be resolved
i'm making my job you nailed it there
they are they don't want to deal with
the headache and i've caught prosecutors
in
massive narco-trafficking cases burying
evidence of innocence i waited a year
and a half till i got to the first
witness in trial and exposed it and got
those cases thrown out my next move was
like hey judge you want to
issue contempt proceedings this person
lied to you for 18 months and we just
proved it and the case just got tossed
and every time they're like well
uh let's talk about it later i got to
work with the us attorney's office i got
to work with the defense bar you know i
don't want to be out there when i got uh
uh falsely arrested i told you the story
off eric i've sat on air too many times
but when i got falsely arrested when i
was a teenager i was told by the police
the reason they so long story short my
brother and i got attacked jumped and
beat up by security guards because of
mistaken identity or something to that
effect
when the when we talked to the cops they
said look
you know we know that you guys didn't do
anything wrong now everything's been
resolved but we got to work with these
guys you know they're a big part of the
economy here in the small suburb we get
calls from all the time if we get into
it the security guys it's going to be a
nightmare for us so we're going to let
them get away with the attack on you and
enjoy you know i hope you enjoyed the
the eight months of your lives you spent
in and out of court and all the money
you lost that's how it works
the state is friends with the state and
the system well you one thing to
remember uh with these judges and this
is a problem with the system is that
they often work in the same like in my
town they're they're effectively offices
are in the same building as the
prosecutors
um and and they're in when they're not
in their offices they're just in court
and they have these cattle call hearings
and so you're sitting there with the the
prosecutor their their co-workers for
five hours straight as they go through
uh this this big stack of files defense
attorneys you know file in and out and
some of them get get friendly but but
the other issue that the judge can
always fall back on is well
yeah
in this case kyle would have been
prejudiced if he was found guilty but he
wasn't prejudiced because the jury came
to the right conclusion so since there's
no harm you know it really doesn't look
good to do it uh to go back and revisit
this issue and that's why i was on the
same page with you uh once he said well
why don't we we could put you guys on
the stand uh under oath and get an
expert in here i'm like yeah do it judge
dismiss the journal 10 minutes
dismiss the jury for the day for a week
whatever you need however long you need
to get an expert let's put these
prosecutors on the scene let's get them
under oath talking about how they
emailed it to their personal gmail
account from their gov account and then
and then sent it when everything else
was sent by dropbox you give
explanations 30 seconds on that laptop
and i can tell you if he did it or not
30 seconds you pull up the log files and
you can see what they did
like that yep
10 minutes
10 minutes to put him on the stand jerry
can wait have a bag of doritos while
they're waiting a little
give him some pop give him some pepsi
now the other person that can do
something with that
is kyle yep right it you know putting
aside the defamation stuff
one instance because it's basically
that case i would take if i were
advising him i would take that to
federal court for violation of his civil
rights right that's what happens when
you have prosecutorial misconduct at the
state or federal level your best bet is
this whole thing that you see in the
movies like i'm going to sue you for
melissa's prosecution that doesn't
really exist
it's like really hard
yeah like
one in a bazillion but what you can do i
mean suing for a violation of civil
rights is also very difficult but it's
very it's very real in this case this
guy this kid was charged with capital
murder and the prosecution doctor as
evidence that's pretty damn good now
what you'll have to prove in federal
court is hey man you won your trial well
okay my life's now screwed up because of
this because i was labeled a domestic
terrorist falsely a terrorist falsely a
racist falsely you know member of the
cake whatever he ca he's got a good list
to make that case well and he's got a
bunch of
uh news news organizations dutifully
reporting that he raised his gun and
provoked and provoked the attack and
that the the ruling is unjust because of
that so um the the news can kind of feed
this in and if he's got civil attorneys
or if he's got prospective civil
attorneys
who are thinking about things like this
you know hopefully they'll be capturing
those things and it's it's not going to
go against the news companies but it's
going to say this is the result of the
state infringing on my client's civil
rights and here's the damage that was
done because now it's it's all over the
major media that he provoked an attack
that he never did and and real quick
sorry you can quantify damages from a
media sense in terms of pr rec
rectification or the work right where
would be basically if they dedicate
one minute
in defaming you and you need to then pay
one minute to counter that lie it's very
expensive
if you guys weren't if you guys were
kyle's lawyers what would be your first
step who would you go after first in
this entire matter the prosecutors the
media the state how would you how would
you navigate that that field
well
whatever he's going to do is going to be
tough um at the end of the day he won
and uh we were talking about libel proof
earlier
part of the problem with the way we
prosecute things is if any opinion out
there is based on the prosecution itself
based on what's in the complaint people
are able to formulate reasonable
opinions based on that now uh there are
issues because a lot of the stuff that's
being reported by some of these places
never happened for example saying that
kyle shot three black men that never
happened so that's not really a subject
of the complaint that's a way to attack
but i mean from for my money uh i'm
going after krauss and the county of
kenosha uh and by extension the state of
wisconsin um on the deprivation of civil
rights i think that's a that's a great
approach um to take and then uh for
defamation it's going to be based on
individual news publications and what
they've said wasn't it the guardian the
other day that said he shot three black
guys the independent the independent uh
so that's going to be tough because
that's in the uk uh so that
unless they have a u.s office i believe
they do a vos office okay so you might
be able to go after them but you're
really going to have to do very careful
sifting as we saw with sandman right
they had something like 57 statements
and only three went through because
almost all of them are opinion anything
that says kyle's a white supremacist
that he's a racist uh that he was
racially motivated those are going to
probably be opinion statements but they
all said he crossed state lines the gun
that's the statement of fact right right
that's that's that's a
on its face a defense defamatory
statement then the next thing so kyle's
kyle's a little bit of a different um
he's differently situated than almost
anyone else would be right the second he
got arrested this case went global right
so what they will argue is not against
the defamation they will argue that
kyle's a public figure right so once you
become a public figure man that
defamation hurdle is huge it is you in
order to show damages you have to
satisfy this bar that's almost
impossible to satisfy even if you prove
kyle did not cross state lines with a
gun kyle did not shoot three black men
kyle is not a domestic terrorist he's
not a racist or a member of whatever
that's the what i would recommend to
kyle and his crew
is that i would write an open letter to
the department of justice for them to
initiate a federal civil rights
investigation of the kenosha county
prosecutor's office and the police that
investigated this case because they have
done that repeatedly in the past when
there has been racial unrest and cities
were burning that's doj's biggest civil
war i think the doj is more likely to go
after kyle no i agree i would just make
this i would do that right as part of a
sort of a grander media strategy to be
like we asked the department to come in
and do x they said no now i have my
rights under defamation and this and
that and what other options do you guys
think the tucker carlson documentary
complicates this because it kind of
paints him as a public figure always
look whenever you're making statement
like you never hear me talking about my
defamation cases except to say the
pleadings are public the instance is
there they lied about this meeting
that's all i say if you give an
interview on that these lawyers are
going to go in there and just tear you
apart and use that in pleadings yeah
because target carlson was filming a
documentary on kyle during the entire
court proceeding so which i agree with
kyle's defense lawyer yeah i would have
been like no way no you're out you
cannot cannot be here but it's kyle's
choice at the end of the day
yeah if it's kyle's choice at the end of
the day it might be someone else's
choice uh we don't really know but i'm
really glad you mentioned the the
the media the grander media strategy
because um we're talking about how hard
these cases are to win that doesn't mean
that a defamation case can't be valuable
yes whether whether you win or not you
know kyle's got this big dilemma he's 18
years old and he's facing a life where
his name will forever be tainted by what
happened to him and that's really unfair
but a defamation case can be a way to
launch himself into
if he wants to embrace a media spotlight
he can become a spokesman a spokesman
against stuff and a defamation case is a
way to do that talk about the the broken
prosecution system talk about the fact
that media can run roughshod over people
raise a lot of money doing it get some
sponsorships behind him and and become a
media figure in the way that uh you know
some of the parkland kids have done um
yeah you know they they've taken that
you know obviously different uh side of
the political spectrum but there there
is a way to make a career out of that
when otherwise his careers prospects got
chopped down considerably from the
average 18 year old well let me ask you
in if if you're a public figure or
involuntary public figure i think what
they call the covington kids then the
standard would be
actual malice or gross negligence
regarding the facts right it's it's
actual malice is yeah for for any public
figure so but
doesn't it also include gross negligence
no that's different
really like actual malice gross
negligence really
i thought even if you're a public figure
then
like your intent it's your intent so you
so
even though
if you watch the trial for even 10
minutes
even even though you could look at any
of the filings
when they lie
about when they say he crossed state
lines the gun
right now even though dominic black is
currently in in being prosecuted
literally for
giving the gun to to kyle
in wisconsin
that's not actionable so the the actual
malice standard from a journalistic
perspective is that
the journalist and this is this is so
frustrating the journalistic uh outlet
has to have a standard that they would
typically do to conduct research and
they have to fail to meet that standard
that's the gross negligence i think
you're talking about right is is that
they still that's how you show actual
malice is if they have a standard and
then they fail to meet the research
standards that they would otherwise do
okay okay i will tell you this then if
kyle rittenhouse files a loss he
absolutely should sue every single one
of these outlets because i will love it
when they're like our standard does it
include using google we we don't take 10
seconds to google search any of these
things we just say them because we made
them up but here's the here's the kicker
they'll be happy this is part of the
reason i'm out there like raising all
this money for people's defamations
lawsuits it's not just yes there's
insane amount of value in bringing cases
that have some merit right but like you
said the biggest obstacle is money so
i'll you know we'll take care of that
and fight with cash we'll pay for your
lawyers and we'll review your case for
free but the other kicker in bringing
defamation suits if you bring him in the
right state courts it's that they have
to divulge once you get past this like
mid-trial phase called summary judgment
they the defense has to disclose their
sources
to this plaintiff really why is that
important because then you're because
what the judge has decided is well this
case has enough fact issue to go to a
jury i the judge i'm out of ruling on
that now here we go discovery and oh by
the way you don't want to settle you the
defense like in virginia state law which
is where all my cases are being brought
they have to once we get past summary
judgment tell me who is the sources of
your stories and if they fail to do that
to default judgment what if they lie or
well let me give you again i guess they
could that's always possible but i think
that's why what's the worst so if if
they say we will not reveal our sources
it's a default judgment you win wow
that's why uh devin nunes brings a lot
of cases in virginia right yeah so devin
and i uh dear friend my former boss he
actually had a huge win in federal court
um in the appellate court about a month
ago
and um yeah we bring uh we just bring
cases to clear our names you know
devon's a little different he's like the
public figure of public figures
russiagate but he's doing it for the
reasons we're talking about yes he was
defamed yes they attacked his 90 year
old grandmother right and he realizes
the bar is very high but what happens is
we're trying to correct the media and
the way you do that is you issue a
monetary judgment against them the other
way you do that is you take them to
federal court get past summary judgment
and get their sources and tell the world
yeah that that's the that hurts that's
one of the the strategy when someone
lies against you you you have two
options money or the truth yeah or both
i mean hopefully you get both but uh but
a lot of people will lose a defamation
suit but uh they'll lose the judgment
but uh people will get the option of
seeing oh there's another side of this
story and those stories will
consequently get a lot of media coverage
because the initial story got a lot of
media coverage and that can have a ton
of value in itself to rehabilitate to at
least tell hey at least the people who
don't hate me you know what i didn't do
any of this stuff that they're saying
they're lying about me you know they're
lying about me and and that can have a
lot of value too the problem right now
is
if cnn came out and said you know uh
riketa
hates chocolate ice cream something you
know it's true and no no but it's not
true it's not true
anybody who likes cnn
well maybe you're not a good example
let's say trump let's say cena comes out
and says trump report uh trump hates
chocolate ice cream chocolate ice cream
according to those familiar with his
thinking as the you know that ridiculous
line they like to use
anybody who likes trump is going to say
they're lying and then trouble like it's
not true i love chocolate ice cream and
then anybody who hates trump is going to
believe cnn right right so it's like
there's almost no point even bothering
except for monetary damages
it depends uh it depends on the
polarization of the figure i mean trump
is an extremely polarized figure
more than probably anyone else on earth
right um but for uh
for devin nunes you know for someone
who's maybe um 75 percent of the way to
trump's level of polarization uh i i
think there's value there i i really do
with co i guess kyle's too polarizing
kylo renounced i don't think so
personally yeah
is kind of unknown it's more about the
media's portrayal i mean at the moment
they're calling for his death he just
came out and said he supports black
lives matter yeah right he also said
he's he's sick of the left and right
using his case in order to push their
political agenda so he's coming out and
making a lot of statements which uh are
shocking and surprising a lot of people
including people on the right and those
statements are the ones that actually
carry weight in court and when you get
when you get rulings that's when people
start paying attention you're never
going to get his message that of that
message of saying i'm on the left and
the right or i'm in the middle out there
unless you actually get rulings in court
and that's why he's got to bring those
cases it's it's a mistake for kyle
rittenhouse to come out and say that
he's supporting black lives matter or
criticizing
one side over the other probably should
just avoid the polarization surgery all
together totally but i'll put it this
way one of the problems i see with
i guess we'd call it the right
was one of the jurors
this was going around um when asked
in jury selection he said he wouldn't be
a good juror he would be fair because
he's pro 2a and he supports gun rights
that was a that's a big thing right and
that's that right there is like
i agree with our constitutional rights
so i shouldn't be involved in this
because only people who don't agree with
kyle's rights should be judging him
yeah the there's a there's this weird
proclivity of people who are honest to
be honest to the fault of themselves
no one is going to be able to remove
every bit of bias from from their
decision making anybody who goes into a
jury the person i trust lease is a
person who's like oh yeah i can ignore
all of my biases when making this jury
decision
yeah
everybody's got some biases the question
is can you can you reasonably make
decisions and a lot of people do that
every day um
the real issue with that is when you've
got a criminal case the person who says
oh man i don't know if i could be
impartial in this that's the guy who's
going to be the not guilty vote right
like that's never going to be the guilty
vote if the guy's like i hate this guy
he's not going to go oh i i you know i
just can't be partial on or impartial on
this i'm going to stay on the or i need
to leave the jury no if you if you hate
the defendant then you're going to want
to be on that journey and most judges
look the the job of the prosecution
defense when you're doing jury selection
is to strike people you don't like or
you think you don't like or there's a
possibility of you not liking them what
happens though 99 of the times is you
get someone to say yeah you know what
i'm not going to be fair in this case
because of my pro-2a position the judge
jumps in and says well actually you know
remind me i'll remind you this is jury
service it's a constitutional right
goes through a litany of legal things
and then basically asks them again are
you sure you can't set that aside we're
not asking you not to be pro 2a just
said
are you sure you can't set it aside and
be in part set it aside the judge should
say
uh just to point out the second
amendment is a constitutional right
right if you're saying that you are
opposed to constitutional rights
then perhaps i understand your argument
you're being too pragmatic
i i would be i'd be a crazy judge the
judges want see what the judges don't
want to do is dismiss everyone because
you could pretty much dismiss 95 of all
jurors in any trial at any given time if
you didn't if you didn't apply that
standard then there would be no jury
trials ever so the judge's job is to be
like we got to really keep these people
in in the box and and despite all of the
the crap that schrader got from the
media about being oh pro you know pro
kyle or whatever in that jury selection
one of the people stood up and said i
just don't believe that anybody should
have a machine gun
and the judge took the time to say well
just so you know like there's no
allegation that anyone in this case had
a machine gun this is a semi-automatic
right and he takes this really
painstaking process to go through and
explain uh that this was not a machine
gun it's not fully automatic it's one
trigger pull one thing it's perfectly
generally legal firearm that's you know
and and he did take pains to do that and
and that is someone who was likely going
to be opposed to to kyle rittenhouse was
that jurors elected i don't know at the
end of the day i don't i don't remember
but it was it was early on in that jury
selection process and that was kind of a
slog i i don't
i don't think i could ever be on a grand
jury or a jury i just outright be like i
am heavily biased against the state
and there is literally nothing that's
ever going to change my mind okay i'll
tell you this they might accept your
word on that
yeah yeah we we were talking with
michael malus on the show and he was
telling the story that he it's i think
it's mostly um fictionalized for legal
purposes but he basically said to a
prosecutor in a grand jury i'm an
anarchist and i will not return an
indictment and he was like well too bad
you're on the grand jury and so he
convinced everybody to return no
indictment and the prosecutor was like
what what just happened it's like do you
let an anarchist on a grand jury they're
going to take charge here's what we
would do with guys like that right we
the judge would call us up sidebar and
be like we're not going to pick this guy
he's going to be the alternate i'm going
to make him sit here for two months
[Laughter]
and it's the judge's calling i i i
become
be
be completely honest
if i got jury duty i'd go there and be
like i would absolutely love to be
involved in this process i love the idea
of jury duty and civic duty and i am
also heavily biased against the state
i'm just being completely honest i would
love to weigh all the evidence and if
you were fair and honest i would make a
fair and honest assessment but keep in
mind i don't trust the state do you have
a do you have a duty to inform the judge
or anyone picking you that you believe
in jury nullification that you believe
you have to tell them
if you believe in that idea even if
you're not actually sure
it's just literally illegal so
like as a defense attorney as a public
defender i wanted to argue jury
nullification like look at my poor
client you know he's just yeah yeah yeah
the state versus you know this penniless
popper you can't do that there's crafty
ways to get around that but the other
thing about jury selection is
about 80 of your reversals come from
improper jury selection this is why
judges are so guarded against it because
they want to make sure it's the racial
thing it's called batson challenges or
whatever like you can't every every
juror has a racial profile under the law
and you can't strike one just for some
race decision and a lot of reversals
come because the defense and the
prosecution don't do enough to
to to what we call state the record of
what the case actually is and the judge
screws up and that's where a lot of
reversals come in what the first i've
heard the jury nullification is illegal
what's the history of that i thought it
was totally legal no you can't with the
the premise is you have to be able to
argue the facts that are presented in
the case right and the facts that are
presented in the case as to whatever the
charges you can't go in there and be
like
uh this guy has had the worst life in
human history this is why you should
acquit him of murder because he's just
you know has had the worst luck has been
stabbed has been you know shot at his
his mother died that's why you should
acquit him you can't say that you can
say you should acquit him because
he's had a rough life but in the
instance of the murder thing he actually
didn't do it whatever what if what if
it's like a drug charge and you don't
believe in the in the law like you don't
believe the law should have been implied
here because you don't believe in
victimless crimes and and you don't
think this should be used on him so
that's why you want to nullify this by
voting as a juror and saying this this
shouldn't be applied here then then what
should happen is the the state
should be very careful in what questions
that they ask the jury on voidir and if
they don't ask you those questions then
you don't have to answer those questions
but you keep it to yourself you don't
stand up and say i believe in jury
nullification if you're going to go
nullify a jury and by the way i fully
100 support during nullification this
show is brought to you by jury
nullification
no uh i i 100 support it if if you
believe a law is unjust and you are on a
jury for it then you have that right but
you cannot stand up and tell the judge
and the prosecutor and the defense
attorney that you're going to do it
defense attorneys can't argue for it and
uh and if they do that's one of the the
few ways that a defense can get a
mistrial um and a redo at it so wait
wait wait i didn't
what would happen if you were on the
jury like you got on there you were
selected and then when you were walking
one day said i'm going to nullify the
i'm going to i'm going to they'll just
they'll just dismiss you yeah yeah
they'll dismiss you as a juror same same
thing they had with the way to get out
of it yeah getting out of jury duty is
really easy what you do is you go to the
bailiff and you tell a racial joke
for those that don't know that's
actually what happened one of the
journeys yeah yeah i heard the kyle
written house case but it's also
important to know that a lot of people
who were charged under very heavily
heavy drug charges under very heavy
crimes were many times allowed to let go
because of jury nullification because
people said hey this is obscene that
this man was using this substance for
let's just say medicine but there's been
so many different cases and then the
jury said there's no way i agree with
this morally i'm gonna impose jury
nullification i don't know if they
announced it or didn't announce it but i
also heard of cases of people being
arrested outside of court courthouses
because they were advocating for jury
nullification i also saw videos about
that so is that what you meant cash by
by it being illegal or no it's act no
don't get me wrong it is illegal for a
defense attorney to go in there and
argue jury nullification it's unlawful
the defense you cannot do that but as a
citizen as a juror i could practice
let's live in the real world if you have
a jury and they feel but look i would
try cases all the time and be like i
would the way you beat the cops is you
put the cops on trial and make the jury
feel worse for your client than law
enforcement you're playing to jury
nullification by trying to address facts
that show that and juries are going to
be hip to that and they they can make
that ruling on their own you just can't
openly argue for it you can pitch it and
of course juries do that all the time so
you could you could say something like
you could say
you know
a guy was arrested with cbd
and they're arguing it's an illegal drug
which is completely unfair here's the
facts so even though technically the
state is correct the jury's probably
going to be like yeah but you can't tell
them that they have they could do that
exactly you can't say it and you can't
if you're you're on a pretty thin line
because a smart prosecutor will jump up
and be like that's jury notification and
the judge will come down on you yeah but
as a citizen a lot of people don't even
know what it means a lot of people don't
even don't even understand what jury
nullification is or victimless crimes so
i think you know talking about it and
and spreading this kind of word letting
people know that the average citizen if
they participate in our court
proceedings have a right to throw down
unjust laws i mean that's a big judge a
judge will tell you no that's unlawful
hillary's instruction will be it's
unlawful if they decide to do it what
are they going to do right like how are
they going to i mean to be honest the
judge says if you believe the state has
proven you know these things about a
reasonable doubt so you just be like i
didn't believe him yeah you didn't meet
the bar oh okay
yep and that that's the way but but it's
remember that when you're when you're
under void year you're under oath and
you are required to answer those
questions truthfully under penalty of
perjury and so you know it's really up
to the state to craft their questions to
try and eliminate things like jury
nullification and that's why um that's
that's why you saw uh in fact some of
these uh race-based dismissals uh
cropping up is because you know in
in the south for example deering jim
crow you might have a white defendant
and a black victim and you would have a
jury that they would try and strike any
black jurors from that jury because they
would want a jury nullification even if
the facts mixed up based on race so jury
nullification it can be used in an
inappropriate way it has in the past but
now we tend to think of it as more of a
liberty minded position attacking things
like victimless crimes and and that
frankly lies at the feet of things like
mandatory minimum sentences when when
you've got people who have like four
marijuana plants going a mandatory
minimum of 20 years in a federal prison
someone goes that's not really justified
when when joseph rosenbaum gets out and
ate yeah but people don't know this you
know they right they sit on a jury the
judge says it doesn't matter what your
opinion is the law it matters why
instruct you and they say okay
i'll lock the guy up that's what what
mal's was telling us he said you know do
you really want this kid's life to be
completely ruined do you want to be the
people you'll have this on your
conscience for the rest of your life
that you destroyed this person's life
over what a substance or something and
then people were like yeah i don't wanna
that my attitude on this is the reason
why i would almost pro like if i was on
a grand jury almost never indict is
because i i'm not the judge over other
people sorry like i can i can certainly
have my opinions and be judgmental but
like to actually tell me we are going to
grant you partial power along with this
other group to condemn a person to
either
a court proceeding which is arduous and
difficult or as a jury itself to jail
prison or death i'd be like but that's
like going on here that's why grand
juries are so big right yeah that's why
there's like you know 32 members of a
grand jury the preponderance of the
evidence standard is 51 49
not you know did he maybe do it versus
did he not do it and also you only need
like 17 of the 32 i forget the exact
breakdown so and you put me on a grand
jury over property crime or possession
or anything like that and i'm going to
be like
thumbs down
sorry
i mean and i and obviously i'm i think
crime is bad property crime and stuff if
it's like victimless stuff like
literally someone chilling in their
house minding their own business with
some some weird thing you know that
they're not supposed to the government
says you're not allowed to have i'd be
like nah government's wrong what if
they're playing videos from facial abuse
on a big screen outside in the front
lawn what would you do then they're
doing what playing videos from facial
abuse on a big screen facial
never mind we probably shouldn't get
into it
i'll put this away
i don't know if it's like
don't worry about it but
i don't know if it was like it was like
a good esoteric joke no it's it's like a
a a violent pornographic website right
uh oh okay okay um uh
i think that's a civil issue
there you go i think i think you can
potentially argue like minor disorderly
or something or disturbing the piece
which i really am not a fan of is a law
because like dude tell me what i did
wrong cop you know like i was telling
that story the cop claimed that because
i was yelling night call 9-1-1 i was
being disordered i'm not kidding they
were like he was yelling and i was like
i was yelling call the police like and
they're like we don't care so i didn't
want to do those jobs so look
you know if you've got a person who's
projecting you know really inappropriate
stuff i don't believe in obscenity laws
uh i think george crown was right when
he went out and started you know said
the seven words you can't say on tv and
if the neighbors got a problem with it i
think you've got a civil issue where the
neighbors can maybe take up some kind of
civil complaint um and maybe this is
resolved i don't think it's criminal you
know what i mean right if a guy is
putting video of himself naked out no no
no no if if somebody was projecting on
their own home
inappropriate oh i thought it was out
front in their yard yes so like on the
front of their house they're showing
inappropriate things like on your garage
that's what i do exposing yourself in
public kind of no ian's right i'm just
talking about general
what's considered you don't need to talk
about and get into specifics because
we're trying to be family friendly the
point is how can you not object to that
stuff though i i do and i think it's a
civil issue not a criminal issue i don't
think the police should come and arrest
a guy because he was making a statement
depending on who he's made when the
police are allowed to be like this is
obscene they'll say your politics are
obscene too so
if someone's like i believe in these
things and i'm gonna i think people
there's nudists this is a political view
on on clothing and the rights of
individuals and there are women who walk
around naked in new york city and are
not necessarily naked topless because in
new york city they're allowed to
so if somebody wants to make a statement
about what they deem as socially
acceptable or not and it's a public
statement i would argue it's a civil
issue and there's potentially disturbing
the peace there but i probably would not
indict there's that entire feminist
movement right feman uh that's what they
do they're they're topless and they
paint uh no no no no no no no
sorry i dropped you oh yeah yeah you're
going well beyond them being topless
okay i haven't checked in on it lately
they the stuff i i've i was in ukraine
and the things i was told about the
stuff they do is like
hardcore overt and i can't say it wow
did you see the uh but have you ever
seen my favorite feman clip is when the
one runs at putin and he gives her the
thumbs up right before she gets tackled
i wouldn't indict
look my dad's pretty funny if it
involves kids
if someone's doing something
you know wrong with kids i'll be like
consenting adults i contending adults
can do what they want to do man leave me
out of that business that's right if
someone's projecting it on their house
and my son is in his room looking out
the window at it i'm like well now we
got a problem and it might be criminal
no uh you go and you close his window
and say son don't look outside or if
he's sitting in the front yard you come
inside i'm why would i let him put me
out no no you can't you can't what do
you mean he put you out if he's going to
force me to hide my son indoors and bar
the windows
but that's a civil matter it's it's uh
it's a public it's a it's a nuisance uh
it's it's not a trespass because they're
not physically intruding on your
property but uh we have a whole uh tort
called uh nuisance and and it's when you
interfere with the quiet enjoyment of
someone's property that's a that's a
civil tort so that exists out there it's
it's for this exact same thing if you
have like an offensive smell uh say
someone buys a property next to you and
puts in a pig farm or whatever right and
then no it happens yeah
yeah and and so or or they put a bees
right like they put up bees and the bees
are coming in and stinging your kids or
something like that uh you you have uh
you have different ways to deal with a
civilian i think i i fully agree with
tim but but i would say ian like your
perspective is overtly authoritarian
well i'm talking about like porn if it's
like doesn't matter grotesque it starts
with that but then where does it go
after that
hold on if
the video is depicting illegal
activities well then then i think
there's a question about what they're
showing if it's 18 and over activities
actually that's a good point that might
be criminal
showing uh uh uh adult content that
requires you to be above over 18
publicly might yeah it might be crime
could be that was the first could be
thought of yeah we were talking about
earlier so you have to have criminal you
have to have you actually the city would
actually have to have a law that states
that showing this type of stuff you know
the public display of these images is is
uh not allowed and
some of some of those get struck down as
being over broad and even if you're
prosecuted for them and they they've
been on the books you have an
over-breath uh case there are federal
pornography statutes on the books that
basically say if you
if you show the wrong audience and i
forget what the wrong audience is off
the top of my head but basically kids of
a certain age
x or it's shown to x number of people
you can get into a federal crime so
a smart prosecutor would or savvy one
would be like you might just be showing
it on your house but there's probably
like a thousand people coming by seeing
it so you can basically be in what's
called the distribution business so you
get them on the uh you get them on the
violation of the broadcast right yeah
but a lot a lot i rep as a public
defender i had to represent a lot of
people charged with some pretty nasty
sex crimes one of them was
dis uh distribution of pornography and
there there's not just like distribution
of pornography isn't sending someone
playboys it can happen
in a variety of ways like live audiences
just giving somebody a memory stick and
being like yo check this in a better
example would be they were showing if
they projected video of a a cow
slottery or something
you know so you're actually seeing
videos of the cows get mounted up and
have their throat slit or whatever and
it's just you know blood spilling out
and stuff so the issue there is this is
really interesting um
when i was doing hostile environment
training they showed a video of a pig
femoral artery bleed
on purpose a guy just flopped to the
floor passed out
so um bleeds in some people trigger a
response i forgot there's a nerve legal
response what is it they will respond
and so basically
out of this you know 40 people in the
room one guy saw the video and just
flopped the ground blood pressure
dropped he went unconscious
so the instructor came and lifted his
legs up to put the blood pressure back
into his head and then he immediately
tries getting up and the guy screamed at
him don't move don't get up and the guy
was like i'm fine he goes no you're not
you're only conscious because i'm
holding your legs up
but so that's an interesting question
if
that uh if it is known among these like
hostile this is these are like special
forces guys if it is known among them
that you can trigger a reaction to
people which can be serious and
medically uh problematic by showing a
video
maybe maybe it's flashes and some could
be epileptic now we're talking about
potential criminal intent to do harm to
others well that's uh what happened to
eichenwald right right people were
tweeting it kurt eichenwald the uh the
flashing images and uh and he allegedly
had an epileptic seizure response to it
or he's just epileptic
yeah so he said it was an attempt on my
life or something like that and they
charged the guy yeah they the the texas
court
i would say strained the uh the federal
battery statute or the yeah because it
was a federal crime uh the federal
battery statutes on that one by saying
that the photons from the the thing
hitting his eyes because that that was
intended for those lasers where right
we're actually directing a beam into
someone's eyes for the intent of injury
in my opinion but uh yeah that that was
wild also kurt eichenwald is a weirdo
yeah
well that's that's that's him and uh for
all uh we'll just we'll leave him to his
vices i suppose him and his family uh
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash the like button subscribe
to the channel and go to timcast.com
become a member we are going to oh louie
luke just get in front of the camera not
even paying attention yeah
no no no regard luke see his big old
face starring lou said good yeah go to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
and we're gonna talk a lot about some of
the darker stuff in the in the ring
house case for sure
and and and the law like we already
started getting into some dark territory
right there but we'll we're gonna we're
gonna talk
we're gonna talk about some stuff that's
probably not family friendly in the
members section become a member but
let's read some super chats all right
let's see jordan jones says raketa law
how tall is tim is he a socialist 5 8 or
a normal normal 5 8
also kermit or wisconsin voice your
intro
uh oh okay uh
hi i'm uh nick ricada of arcada law
small law firm in uh
central wisconsin
and uh thanks for thanks for watching
your honor can you say don't you know
don't you know
the funniest thing is when i meet people
i meet a lot of people they either think
that they go wow i thought you were
going to be shorter or they say wow
you're a lot who know they say i thought
they either think i'm really taller i
think i'm really short yeah you're exact
height i thought you would be perfect
the funny thing is though it's because
it depends on which selfie they've seen
with me
so like when charlie kirk and vosh are
here and they're both six three or
whatever like charlie's six five and
washer six three and i'm five ten or
whatever i look very small and i'm like
hey
but then we have like you know michael
malus or or someone or like you know
with joe rogan and they're i think like
five seven then i look a lot taller and
so depending on which episode you've
seen i met a guy at the airport and he's
like wow you're massive what and i was
like all right he's like thanksgiving
and it's also too like the cameras point
down at a slight angle they're slightly
above and then down
and um one of them actually caches is
like on the ceiling basically so am i
gonna look really tall
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry buddy
yeah all right let's see let's see
chase t says was rogan hung over on your
jre episode or just off
i don't know why oh did that come out
today uh on your episode your episode
did come out today you know um a little
late but yeah yeah i was kind of bummed
because we talked we were talking a lot
about the written house stuff
and we were waiting for the verdict
because it was recorded last wednesday
so it comes out on a monday
and the verdict came in last week so
i mean i guess it's a good monday for a
lot of people who didn't know a lot of
details uh there's a lot of people who
probably watched who believe the lies
and i was able to clear a lot of things
up about a lot of what happened
though you know
i don't know i'd probably be called
biased because a lot of what i focus on
was how they were lying about kyle how
kyle was you know you know being smeared
and the prosecution and stuff and i
think you know there probably could have
been more points made about the defense
scrubs that didn't come up because i
just didn't care
did you uh did you happen to see the the
cope fest that they had on brian stetler
with david french um
fest yeah were there oh yeah i saw that
david french is like explaining how how
bad the media got the kyle rittenhouse
story and brian setler's like mm-hmm
the whole time
it's embarrassing
i just love that clip where the reporter
is just like i'd like to read you a list
a list of everything we got wrong one
and not really like that but it was
basically like a six minute rundown of
everything they got wrong and it was all
stuff that could have easily been known
the day it happened
hey look i'm really excited to hear them
in in uh uh in their you know defense
filing for the defamation suits
look our standard is to do no research
yes not even not even a minute in fact
we don't even have google there's no
internet in our building
none that checks out
yeah
all right let's see
john r
saw uh i sent a covet micro plush to a
friend with a humorous nut that said
sorry i gave you covet triggered another
friend asked if i if i knew a lawyer who
would help him with a class-action
lawsuit against the unvaxxed i'm running
out of sane friends
whoa
that'd be really funny to get the
sorry i gave you cute i think michael
malus said he has a coveted positive
shirt or something like that uh did he
say that yeah he's positive about kobe
oh yeah
very positive about it
captain jaedub says nick could midwest
lawyer explain the meaning of
littlebinger's email address to my mom i
loved your stream but it also made for
some uncomfortable conversations and
i've actually had people ask me if that
was his real email address uh i don't
know it's um wait but it might be
it was you know those uh those like
people look up uh background check
websites
people ran those and they found it and
and one of his a former email address
was should i say it i mean is that okay
fluffer
flufferboy2004
at yahoo.com i told you that was real
there was like
um i have a friend who's you know pretty
antifa
and just all of his posts are like
rittenhouse bad written house this he
was posting the state has a really
strong case
i i know just really bad law and his
friends who are also antifa are like
stop like
but he was saying like no no hear me out
we were arguing over the facts of the
case and then i said something like you
know the prosecution was was in my
opinion tampering with evidence
and that's that's horrifying precedent
for the future and then he responded
with that's irrelevant to the facts of
the case because the state is
illegitimate and then i said well hold
on we agree
uh uh
okay are we done can we just be like we
both think
uh i'm exaggerating a little bit you're
like you know i'm not a i'm not a
statist for the most part but i'm like
limited government but like when we get
to the point where we're both just like
the prosecution the whole system is
broken and bad i'm like we don't need to
argue about the rest of this
cal written house was found not guilty
we'll move on but can we start from a
place of like the system is broken for a
lot of reasons and then just work our
way up from there that would be very
nice
okay
operator says tim this is an example of
the lefties blanket statement criminal
justice reform buy one felon and get
nine free doesn't work
what does that mean like one person one
innocent person should go free i don't
know oh we're gonna buy one felon and
get nine free like i'm not sure
maybe if you maybe by uh
maybe it's what you were talking about
earlier where you've got 16 people and
you go okay first one to come to me oh
yeah yeah so you you buy one guy and
then you get the rest of them maybe that
stimulus i don't know
yeah i'll i'll i'll i'll be more uh
specific and when i say like i'd
probably never indict or convict you
would just have to show me
hard proof like there's no there's no
there's no question if you came to me
and said look at this fuzzy video i'd be
like no i don't care you got to show me
literally the dude committing the crime
and if it's like victimless get out of
my face but if you had like this guy
claims it was self-defense and here's
what happened i'd be like well then then
he claimed self-defense it is better
that 10 guilty persons escaped than one
innocent suffer so if he says it was
self-defense unless you can prove
otherwise i'm not convicting and no
emotional argument you got to literally
show me the video there's a video my
brother posted this
um
or actually it's not my brother someone
else it's uh uh it's a close-up shot
from that moment in question where the
prosecution argued that cal brown has
pointed the gun there is a close-up
fairly high resolution have you seen it
it's one yeah one of the cell phone
videos that's right and rosenbaum jumps
out at him and then he turns and he
starts running he never points the gun
he never has a second a chance to do it
but the prosecution just made all this
up the defense didn't find that video
it's everywhere i mean you guys found it
didn't you yeah it's it's it's actually
in the defense's exhibits um yeah
i believe uh it's in there and the key
though is once you get on the record a
piece of evidence you get to use it in
closing argument and that's that's kind
of the lawyer strategy is get these
statements these moments in time that i
can then use to build my story at the
end to the jury and remind them what
they saw and let them ignore a bunch of
stuff that they saw too
and and the key to this that everybody
needs to understand is that all of this
comes from one detective looking at a
drone video that's grainy and tiny
already on an iphone that no one can
verify that's the only testimony that he
raised the gun and they had the
opportunity to bring in the zaminski's
they could have granted immunity on the
one arson charge for joshua zaminski
he's got a million other uh issues in
his past this is not necessary they
could have granted him immunity to give
to get rid of the fifth amendment issue
and had him testify to raising the gun
the reason they didn't is probably
because he's a scary communist
revolutionary who would be unpredictable
on the stand and they know it
someone is
what is this
someone spamming i guess oh
yeah oh well all right let's see daniel
maxwell says we should always treat
those who are accused of criminal act as
innocent until proven guilty in court if
we fail to do that then we will become
what the woke far left accused of all
accuse us all of being uh i always do
always this morning with the guy in
waukesha he wasn't arrested he was a
person of interest and a lot of people
were like he was politically motivated
they're outright saying it he's a blm
supporter i'm like he was a blm
supporter it may be politically
motivated we have no evidence he's that
he's the actual suspect or committed the
crime we only know him as a person of
interest for all we know he was at home
sleeping someone stole his car i mean
maybe not i mean the likelihood is
probably that this dude got in his car
and you know there's a picture of him
inside the car yeah but it's not it's
i'll tell you this i will tell you this
if i was sitting on a jury and said
here's the photo that everyone's posting
on the internet and here's a photo of
him i'd be like nah not guilty
like it's a blurry low resolution photo
you can see a face and a beard and so i
can be like maybe but you want me to
lock a guy up for a long period of time
on that dude get ready for defects when
they show a video of the guy saying
things that he didn't actually say oh
yeah and what do you do i mean look at
this they were able to get computer
generated images admitted in evidence
because none of them had the experience
what happens if the process let me and
answer
let me ask you guys what happens if the
prosecution says we've uncovered this
video and it is i mean you've seen the
deep fakes and they're like and it shows
the defendant plotting you know the
attack well i mean look if it's an
actual deep fake you know a prosecutor
should never use it but that's not
saying it won't happen or if they don't
know how do you how do you well first of
all i think the the amount of forensic
tools you have at your disposal as a
prosecutor you can find out basically
what you're saying is like an agent
brings you a video that the agent knows
his deep fake doesn't tell the
prosecutor and the prosecutor just like
no no no
they get a unicorn bit of evidence on a
friday you know five days into the trial
that appears and it's a video and it's
low res but clearly depicts the
defendant and he's saying like
i'm going to walk over to these guys i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna get him i'm
gonna get him triggered i'm gonna get
him and then as soon as they come after
me i'll take him out and claim
self-defense
what if the prosecutor gets there and
goes whoa
we got him
well the way this is supposed to be
handled and was not handled in this way
in the kyle rittenhouse case is the
defense is not supposed to stipulate to
the authenticity of pretty much anything
especially when the so when you're when
you're in court trying to introduce
evidence you have to lay foundation you
have to say where did this come from how
do you know it's true what what thing is
that's why you have to introduce
evidence through a witness the witness
for the prosecution on all of the videos
was a detective
and they said how do you know that these
are accurate and he said well i went on
twitter and youtube and downloaded the
videos
and again this is another detective
who's not there that night
if if any uh anybody on the defense bar
is watching the kyle written house trial
and not understanding how damaging
that
uh the allowance of that evidence in um
through those means was especially when
the drone video came in the same way
even though it's an emergency piece of
evidence and should put through be put
through higher levels of scrutiny
because it's coming in in the middle of
trial and they've had no time to prep
for it
if no one if they're not looking at that
they're they're insane you need to get
the person who took the video who was
there that night like drew hernandez
like richie mcginnis like age gross
quits they had three good sources oh or
uh the the one guy they were all bad
though for the prosecutors well right
and that's because the facts were bad
for the prosecutors but uh the the other
guy the defense witness is brought in i
can't remember his daughter he was in
the the car with his daughter and they
had the cell phone footage you know uh
that they brought in my audience called
him juan wick but whatever um
that's why you can bring those people in
subject them to cross-examination what
were you doing why were you filming this
why did this catch your attention what
was up with that those are the questions
you're supposed to ask to lay the
foundation for the evidence and a lot of
that evidence came in with just a
detective saying well i went to a
website and downloaded a video it's like
is it a full video was it edited was it
cropped does it have a specific slant to
it you know
who took this video and he had no idea
but you don't have to so this is where a
lot of a lot of uh defense attorneys get
it wrong you do not have to be
a witness or there in the time that that
photo or video was taken to lay the
foundation the predicate foundation if
that goes to chain of custody and that's
a judge decides that it doesn't go to a
jury but if you can subject yourself to
cross-examination and be credible in
saying yes that's what it looks like for
all these reasons
you can be the chain of custody witness
yeah but you you have to be able to
testify that what is on the screen is a
fair and accurate accurate
representation of what happened and when
you get attenuated by by a detective who
who sold testimony and this is this is
again the defense's fault in this case
uh the the the guy's sold testimony is i
went to twitter and youtube and i
downloaded your videos yeah this is
insane yeah so so you have no idea where
these videos came from
right you don't know when the files were
created ex and that's that's exactly and
you know you tell me if these videos
were
manipulated or edited in any way and
even if the defense screwed up on this
piece which they did like
what judge in their right mind would let
that in alone the judge can always jump
in even if the defense attorney's
clowning around and say where the hell
is this from yeah and trader was
schrader was overly permissive in this
case and and and he he seemed to
indicate throughout the trial that i
want this to go to a jury and be done
kind of as openly as possible and in a
in a standard criminal prosecution
it would be grounds for appeal if kyle
would have been convicted on on several
different places but yeah but he spends
a year in prison after the fact while
he's waiting right uh he was out no but
like if he's if he's convicted and
sentenced he could be he could be taken
in he you yeah you can you can make a
motion that he would be uh subject to
probation and let out on release
conditions that would be in the judge's
discretion but for capital murder that's
a tough one listen most guys when you
get when you get convicted the
prosecutor stands up at the end of the
court and says uh he's a convicted felon
yeah status is different romance ninety
percent of the time you're going in yeah
yeah for that all right let's read
another one we got this one from trunan
on a shop at a pressure battacaf care he
says tim please tell raketa how to say
my name so we can get it right in the
future super chats love both your guests
tonight and all the uh and all the
compound usual suspects
so i guess um you've been mispronouncing
true nanasha pressure
probably
uh i painstakingly tr uh transcribed
what joe biden said truin
inanna
shabba de pressure
i said what now i i sat there i slowed
it down
to pressure yes it sounds like he was
saying we're gonna do true international
something under pressure true
international yeah can that be the next
blimp luke yeah
i think it makes sense you know
the more blimps the better yeah we have
the i'm probe limp we built the blind
but luca's idea is to put the let's go
brandon on it so we you know yeah and
another statement which we can't tell
you here on this family-friendly
platform that i think i'm very proud of
as well that usually hangs up on my i on
my rv i think we should i agree we
should yes put that banner on the blimp
and if you're wondering what that is i
guess we'll have to bring us all up at
the in the less family-friendly
earmuffs for your children if you want
to listen to it episode
it's so much fun heather barrett says
nick will you be covering the lane
maxwell case
jury selection started in some sense but
uh as kesh stated earlier there are no
cameras in federal courtrooms so we will
not be able to cover it in the same way
that we were able to cover the kyle
rittenhouse case
so i will be looking for another full
trial and the the biggest one on the
horizon for me is kim potter the taser
taser taser lady i have heard there will
be cameras in the courtroom for her so
we might be able to do a full trial of
her but uh for for jillaine maxwell it
will be uh it'll be tough could you have
to sit there yeah i mean just like take
notes sit there
stenographer
could you could we fundraise someone to
be there to report to you and you can
make a report almost at the end of every
day of the court proceeding exactly what
happened we can send one of our
journalists we could just send one okay
can we have reporters like every single
day do it they're not great yeah
this is in minnesota right no no no no
no no no maxwell oh no it's in new york
oh maxwell yes yes absolutely
reporter in there yeah if if we have
media reports for jalen maxwell i'm sure
you know
tons of people have been asking me to
have the the panel of lawyers review
this case and talk about it um it the
the question in all of these things is
can we get the information that that's
the main thing so if we have a reliable
source it's not filtered through like
you know cnn abc msnbc uh then then i'm
certain we can put some stuff together
we need a court reporter yeah but
remember in federal court so if you send
anybody in there that's not the lawyers
uh no cell phones yeah no so they'd have
to literally be there writing everything
down then run out at lunch give you an
update it would have to be someone with
legal experience yeah so if you guys
know anyone our reporters couldn't do it
because when they if they say something
like
i think the e6 example for most people
don't understand is with prejudice all i
see all these people on twitter saying
like whoa they said with prejudice like
like they're racist or something that's
not what it means but it's a legal term
it has a different definition so we need
someone who understands that otherwise
imagine you get you know a layman in
there and they say something with
prejudice and he goes because they were
racist i mean i bet look this is pretty
i bet you veritas and o'keefe can get
you somebody tomorrow
yeah
yeah i mean well i would be interested
in this uh as well so feel free to email
me info we are change.org uh but it has
to be a lawyer it has to be someone with
legal expertise because i mean a
paralegal apparently it was just as good
yeah yeah 3l law student yeah yeah yeah
that's not a bad idea yeah there's
that's my email anyway email
jobscast.com and i'd love to get someone
with with legal experience or law
understanding that's going to be a fun
trial oh yeah six weeks
the rolling stone wrote that the media
establishment and uh people in high
society are afraid of what's going to
come out because of this trial so it's
going to be awesome i love the tweets
when like
when um all the celebrities are tweeting
support for rosenbaum
my thing was like stop assuming things
about people i looked at the tweet from
mark ruffalo where he called him jojo
and i'm like
like
a pet name for this guy and i see all
the responses we're like don't you know
what he did don't you know what he did
to children don't you i'm like why do
you all assume good like this guy is
just a poor bumbling fool like you see
them do these things over and over and
over again
i'm sorry i'm sorry if you are of the
opinion that someone like mark ruffalo
has simply made an honest and ignorant
mistake not realizing who he was
supporting
you are the internet's definition of
insane constantly touching the flame and
going out maybe it won't burn this time
wow maybe it won't burn this time
because um this dude does this a lot and
not just him but a bunch of other people
when hollywood actively supports covers
for weinstein the media covers for
epstein they know all about it and now
you hear them cheering for rosenbaum i'm
like maybe it's time to stop desperately
assuming they're people who are just
ignorant and realize
yeah they know exactly what they're
cheering for yeah but we'll talk a bit
more about that
hollywood is filled with some really
nasty bad people i'll leave it at that
fox uh chase racing says nick is the
kind of guy you can trust uh trust with
your drunk naked wife but not your last
glass of the dalmore no joke nick is one
of the smartest nicest funniest guys and
one with a functioning moral compass
that inspires nick you're a class act my
friend hey what's up fox chase thanks
buddy so what's the dow more i'm not
down more it's a it's a scotch
okay so you just steal it for everybody
yeah well down more cigar malt is a
fantastic scotch by the way where did
our papi go what oh my god oh my god
it's over there
it's delicious by the way i'm gonna have
more in a little bit you know we have a
really nice uh booze shelf and we've had
like i would say 90 of people are sober
they come in and say i don't drink
anymore and so i'm like would you like
to park imbibe our delicious and costly
alcohols and they're like oh no not me i
don't drink anymore i'm like oh man but
nick comes in and he's like where's the
whiskey
[Laughter]
sir come with me it's like willy wonka
like look at all of the great whiskey
you can drink i was excited i was like
yes try the puppy you have to try the
papi i've tried two different pappies
that's great they're both great i guess
one technically isn't a papi it's the
family reserve or whatever but one is or
something and it's like the keystone i
like the uh the family reserve i liked
it better the 13 year oh gosh it's good
wow yeah the we have the laphroaig and
apparently it tastes like the bottom of
an ashtray i'm gonna do that one very
small yeah yeah yeah by all means yeah
band-aids i get the band-aid flavor
a little bit of road time
that's great
what do they say it's actually like peat
yeah that's a very mossy very mossy
it's like eating a campfire i mean
that's put out i mean we're not crazy
i'll be honest like i actually
like the taste oh yeah i'm not a drink
or anything but i i like you know that
kind of you know flavor flavor yeah yeah
lagavulin's another one that's just
solid on the smoke and and pete
sharkbite biz says hey tim loved you on
rogan huge fan give a shout out to my
show on youtube sharkbitebiz just
chatted with gwar today about how nfts
are the gateway to the multiverse yeah
the multiverse totally tippy ian would
love it sharkbot sharkbite biz thank you
very much thanks for that thank you nice
missy kin says tim based on the idea
that people act different in front of a
camera do you think that vice news
embedded with the supremacists in
charlottesville hoping it would provoke
them
uh no
uh i don't i actually don't know
actually
i don't know enough about the people who
embedded with the schartzville crew for
that stuff but i actually
trust them a little bit more than i
don't
i don't know them enough
but there's a few reporters who were
involved who had done things of
principle that i remember and i can't
get specific it's been too long but i
remember talking to them and being like
that was a class act they said something
they called out some fake news and we're
like that's bs but vice as a whole man
really went down the gutter it's kind of
crazy to think that like
you know when i was the first person
they hired for vice news they had an
idea they want to do something but they
didn't want to do on the ground
reporting so when i came there and
basically argued with them for six
months about why they should hire me
long story short they said okay all
right maybe vice news will be field
reporting and less just documentary and
so
i actually went on the ground in ukraine
and venezuela and brazil and all these
countries
and then to see where it is now and just
like what it turned into i'm kind of
like
i used to be like did you know that i
was the founding member of vice news now
i'm like i don't know i have nothing to
do with that you're talking about
i don't know no no oh no no i have it on
my twitter like only wikipedia posted
now
now they're like in big bold letters
like everyone should know but uh there
was a point where i was very much like
you know very proud that it be it after
i had left that was doing really well
they were doing great reporting syria
internationally and then it just went
like
it's not really news anymore it's just
like feminism yeah you know yep
i know why too i think i talked about in
the show because i have a friend who was
an executive and it was basically that
the um the investors revolted over the
potential lawsuits they were facing long
story short and so they decided one way
to protect our image with these lawsuits
coming is to embrace feminism
wholeheartedly and make that a core part
of our message and they were just like
okay vice is the hbo one
vice is a
they were on hbo not on showtime but
they're just a big media company they
shot an episode about me oh yeah how was
it
they i went out to tell you right after
i retired and they wanted to just right
and they they came out and filmed me for
two days and they used 67 seconds well
that was they had a daily show
did a daily show and a mag in a magazine
now that story about you know what i was
told
might not be true i don't know um i do
know what i experienced but i was told
by you know someone who was a former or
like higher up
that
lawsuits were a big deal and that they
had they had um accusations against
people in the company over like you know
harassment things like that and they
were like we got to get in front of this
they also had um vice had a really big
pr blunder when one of their hosts of
vice hbo admitted on youtube that he
raped a masseuse and went god
i'll give some legal advice never do
that
he went into great detail holy moly yeah
it was um you know the dude who painted
facebook and then like they they were
like we'll give you stock in exchange
for painting this place and he's like
okay and then he became a
multi-millionaire yes yes i like that
guy i think that was him i could be
wrong oh my gosh
i like him less he's been on rogan he's
like
this really
eccentric artist he did he did a podcast
i i i may be getting this wrong show
something david cho is it him i gotta
look it up yeah um facts check man this
one and i will preface this with
it's been a long time since i've you
know this is years ago this is nine
years ago whatever eight years ago but i
remember being advised when this went
down and he's on youtube in a podcast
being like so there i am at this you
know massage therapy place and he goes
into detail which i won't detail here
what about how he grabbed the woman and
was like very excited and then they were
all like uh
and then like it's definitely david
chose the facebook guy i don't know if
it's the same guy i'm pretty sure that
was him he was on vice you know maybe
yeah and then they were like what do we
do and then they were like i got an idea
nothing just don't say anything you'll
pour fuel on the fire and let it you
know all blow over so welcome to media
huh
all right we'll grab a couple more here
yes it
yes it's
says tim you should have uh you should
have amazon's utopia writers on your
show and discuss what would be revealed
in season two there was also a british
version but only lasted one season it
would be an interesting conversation
great show but very creepy yeah you know
about utopia right you guys no idea
utopia is a show that aired on amazon uh
recently i think it was this past year
about um
yes uh a tech billionaire who is
concerned about overpopulation who's
working to make fake meat decides that
the way to save the planet is to create
a fake pandemic so that he can rush
through a vaccine without proper
approval or testing and the vaccine
actually sterilizes people oh
there you go it's a pretty good show but
it's a little uh on the nose some well
no some of the acting well it's not
really i mean it's just like people
thought it was they had to put a
disclaimer saying this is not
real life in any way and right
this guy wrote this in 2016.
i think it was actually written over a
decade ago yeah did you know that there
was a book called the titan and it was
about a large cruise ship that hits an
iceberg and then sinks with all the rich
people on it
hmm i believe it was called titan right
i think so yeah and it was written like
50 years before they detected that
the titanic sank wow yeah that's true
story true true true story huh crazy
yeah jack says mark ruffalo is from
kenosha wisconsin is that true i gotta
look that up that sounds like yeah one
of those facts that sounds like it's
true but it's not it's like gotta be
yeah yeah
yeah like who would just say oh wow
really yeah it's so weird because you
know being from chicago like we all know
kenosha we all know antioch you know we
all know these places so for me it was
actually it's fairly easy to see through
some of these some of these lies because
when they were like he crossed state
lines i was like from antioch like
he like probably walked out his backyard
like what are you talking about what
does that mean for a lot of people who
don't know anything about illinois
they're assuming that you know he got in
his car drove 100 miles to a city he's
never been to
and that's how the lies work man it's
how they get you that's why i gotta fix
them joseph rosenbaum crossed several
state lines from his convictions in
arizona all the way up to wisconsin yeah
yeah
man
um well we'll do this one more this is a
good one
uh oh wait what's this
joshua r paulson says veritas hired paul
kelly of cali law to file their
complaint to the feds oh really is that
is that new i don't know i don't know
tree climber says alec baldwin trial
yeah what are your quick thoughts on
what's going on with alec baldwin stuff
ooh
quick thoughts okay maybe not
well i'll keep it simple do you think
there will be a any charges or an
indictment i don't think they'll do it
against alec baldwin if they do any
charges or indictment it would be maybe
negligence uh criminal negligence
against one of the the armorer or the
morris more likely that assistant
director or whatever who's he's a guy
who said the gun was clear without and
admitted to the police that he didn't
check it they're going to pay off the
family yeah oh yeah huge check um we got
a regular chat here that i have to read
i think it's really good okay joe joe
biden yes
i like it i i dig it yeah luke you guys
saw that yeah i saw that
it looks like luke writes it down
mark ruffalo tweeting out support for
joe joe biden there you go and only and
the only people who know like only if
you know you know you know what i mean
you know you're kind of like yeah
yikes yikes
all right everybody if you haven't if
you have not already you can help out by
smashing the like button subscribing to
this channel and sharing the show with
all your friends take that url up top
paste it on facebook and twitter and
instagram well you can't really put on
instagram but you can click click that
share button that really helps out don't
forget go to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only segment that
apparently is gonna be very
gross
and not family-friendly i might need
alcohol
you have you are free we definitely need
more got a bunch but we gotta talk about
uh uh you know there's a lot of stuff
with the maxwell trial there's a lot of
stuff with you know rosenbaum and the
aftermath and what we're talking about
with jojo biden we'll get into so make
sure you check that out you can follow
the show at tim cast irl basically
everywhere or like tim cast underscore
irl or something you can follow me
everywhere at tim cast i'll be posting
stuff on instagram more i'm trying to
you know twitter
but uh do you guys wanna uh well ricky
do you want to shout anything out uh
yeah i'll shout out my youtube channel
uh riccata law on youtube i do nightly
live streams at 11 pm central time they
tend to go till 2 a.m central time and
starting wednesday i'll be adding a
daytime show
that will have
an open invitation to a bunch of lawyers
to join the lawyer panel we'll be we'll
be discussing more focused legal topics
on that show and be looking for trials
to follow a la the written house trials
so come check it out cool
uh thanks for having me back guys really
appreciate it real quick uh uh
fightwithcash.com with a k basically
what we're doing
traveling around the country raising
money for people who have been defamed
into platformed all the money i keep
nothing all that goes to lawyers who are
skilled in defamation suits we will pay
for them and we want nothing in return
we want you guys to have your day in
court and help fix the correct media if
kyle's camp is in need of funding let us
know info fight with cash.com more
importantly the best announcement i've
had in a while which i said at the
beginning of the show the merch store
went online at fightwithcash.shop
and all of tim cast audiences gets a
discount tonight just jump in the
discount code tim cast i want that and
you get the jacket you get the beanie
you got the hat you got t-shirts and all
the proceeds all of it go to right back
to the offensive legal trust for
fightwithcash.com so thanks for
everything awesome well cash thank you
for the beanie i might i might have to
start a beanie competition with tim uh
who knows what i appreciate thanks for
sending that to me uh and yeah a lot of
crazy stuff is happening all around the
world especially in holland and belgium
and italy i talked about that
extensively on my youtube channel we are
change and i also did a really special
video about what if what i would do if i
was 21 years of age if i had to start
all over i talked about that exclusively
on
lukeuncensored.com hope to see some of
you guys there thanks for having me that
was great great to see you again man
cash and nick good to meet you man uh
hope to see you guys again wonderful
night ian crossland that's ian
crossland.net check it out peace out and
before we go i have two little bits of
completely unrelated trivia so if you
pass out when you see blood you have a
form of vasovagal syncope so that's
correct it's the vagus nerve that
affects your ability to
handle the side of blood it's like a
strong response and there were not one
but two books that predicted the sinking
of the titanic well before it happened
which is really interesting including
yeah
you guys see that creepy video where the
bailiff in the courtroom's foot
disappears on stream yes
i didn't i was joking when i tweeted it
but people are taking it seriously i
said it was a simulation the whole time
it was just a streaming glitch but i had
people responding like you're crazy and
i'm like i was joking like i see youtube
is a youtube glitch or something this is
why artifacting and compression are very
very important topics for young defense
lawyers to learn this video should be
preserved if it ever comes up again like
any trial it's like i'd like to use
evidence your honor i'd like you to
watch this clip from youtube where the
clap's foot disappears from the court's
feed yeah right
all right everybody head over to
timcast.com become a member and we will
see you all there on 11 or so pm thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you